>> GOOD MORNING.
THE SENATE GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION
WILL COME TO ORDER.
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I NEED TO
ANNOUNCE
THE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE,
SB 984 WAHAB AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN,
SB 1179 DARAZO HAVE BOTH BEEN
PULLED.
UH, WITH THAT, THERE IS NO
QUORUM.
WE KNOW THAT.
AND, UM, WE ARE GOING TO START
AS A COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE.
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU.
AND WE ARE GOING TO.
WHAT ITEM NUMBER IS THAT?
ITEM NUMBER 19.
THE ONLY AUTHOR IN THE HOUSE
IS ME.
AND SO I'M GOING TO DO THAT.
AND, UH, VICE CHAIR WILK WILL
TAKE OVER THE COMMITTEE.
>> I ADJOURN THIS COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
CAN ALL GO HOME?
WHAT'S THE RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS BILL?
NO, NO, NO.
BUT DOES IT GO ANY ANY
AMENDMENTS?
I DON'T HAVE THE.
I'LL GIVE IT TO YOU.
OKAY.
BEAR WITH ME, MR.
CHAIR.
I DIDN'T HAND YOU ALL THE TOOLS
OF THE TRADE.
NO, YOU DID NOT.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
OKAY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 19 SP 896 BY
OUR ILLUSTRIOUS CHAIRMAN, MR.
DODD.
AND THE MOTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED,
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
WHICH I WILL SEE THAT BILL AGAIN
NEXT WEEK.
WITH THAT, THE FLOOR IS YOURS,
SIR.
OKAY.
MR.
CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED ON PAGE 14 OF THE
ANALYSIS.
THE AI ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
ENSURES
THAT STATE AGENCIES ADVANCED
SAFEGUARDS AROUND AI BY
INCORPORATING
AND BUILDING UPON RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDERS FOCUSED ON
THE GOVERNMENT USE OF THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES BY PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
WHEN USED ETHICALLY AND
TRANSPARENTLY,
GENERATIVE AI HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE SERVICE DELIVERY
OUTCOMES AND INCREASE
ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER, JUST AS HUMANS HAVE
EXPLICIT
AND IMPLICIT BIASES BUILT INTO
OUR SOCIETY,
AI HAS THE CAPACITY TO REFLECT
AND AMPLIFY THESE BIASES.
THE BILL.
THIS BILL PROVIDES FURTHER
GUIDANCE
TO STATE ENTITIES AND
ESTABLISHES
GUARDRAILS WHILE CREATING A
FRAMEWORK FOR STATES,
THE STATE'S PROCUREMENT, AND
APPLICATION
OF GENERATIVE AI.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE CREATION AND REGULAR
UPDATING
OF BENEFITS AND RISK OF
GENERATIVE
AI REPORT AND REQUIRES STATE
AGENCY COORDINATION WITH AND
SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNMENT WORKFORCE
IN PREPARING FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION
OF AI SKILLS NEEDED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT, DO YOU HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES?
WE'RE DOING THIS ONE ON OUR
OWN, OKAY?
SEEING NONE.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT CARES
TO WEIGH IN ON SUPPORT.
OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL GO TO THE
NEGATIVE SIDE.
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION?
ARE YOU TAUNTING ME?
YEAH, YOU'RE TAUNTING ME.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT, WE'LL PULL IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR.
>> READY TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN
THE TIME'S RIGHT.
THAT SOUNDS.
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION.
DID YOU DID YOU WRITE THOSE
COMMENTS?
DID YOUR STAFF WRITE THOSE
COMMENTS OR DID ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE WRITE THOSE
COMMENTS?
UNLIKE LAST YEAR WITH THE FIRST
BILL THAT WAS WRITTEN BY.
I.
I WAS GOING TO MENTION THE
COMPANY NAME,
BUT NEVERTHELESS THIS ONE WAS
COMPLETELY WRITTEN BY,
UH, OUR TEAM.
OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
IT'S AUTHENTIC.
OKAY, WELL, THIS BILL SUPPORTS
SUPPORT.
I HAVE NO QUESTIONS MYSELF.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
STAFF.
FIND YOUR FIND YOUR AUTHORS AND
GET THEM DOWN.
OH, I SEE AN AUTHOR RIGHT OVER
THERE.
I'M NO LONGER CHAIR,
SO I'M NOT GOING TO CALL YOU UP.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO CALL YOU
UP.
BUT I WOULD GO UP THERE IF I
WERE YOU.
SENATOR.
SENATOR NEAL, WELCOME.
YOU HAVE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, SB
1104.
I DO.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
YOU KNOW.
>> I JUST, UH, WITH IT THIS
MORNING.
>> UH.
THANK YOU, UH, MR.
CHAIR AND ALL OF THE MEMBERS WHO
ARE HERE, UH,
RIGHT NOW, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY STATING,
AS SENATOR DODD DID FOR HIS
BILL,
THAT I ACCEPT THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ADD
A TEN YEAR SUNSET CLAUSE.
SB 1104 ESTABLISHES THE OFFICE
OF
REGULATORY COUNSEL TO SERVE AS
A CENTRALIZED ENTITY THAT WILL
DRAFT
REGULATIONS FOR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AGENCIES IN A SIMILAR
MANNER
THAT THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL DRAFTS LEGISLATION FOR
THE LEGISLATURE.
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE WORK THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL DOES FOR US IN DRAFTING
BILLS.
OVER TIME, DEPUTIES DEVELOP
EXPERTISE
IN THEIR RESPECTIVE AREAS
AND PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
GUIDANCE
WE RELY ON TO TO PASS STATUTES.
HOWEVER, THERE IS NO SIMILAR
OFFICE
FOR THE DRAFTING OF REGULATIONS.
DRAFTING CLEAR REGULATIONS IS
REALLY NO EASY
TASK FOR STAFF WHO ARE UNTRAINED
TO DO SO,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THAT
THERE ARE 6
TO 700 PROPOSED REGULATIONS
ANNUALLY.
THE NUMBER ONE REASON WHY
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW REJECTS PROPOSED REGULATIONS
IS LACK OF CLARITY.
THIS IS LARGELY BECAUSE MOST OF
THE STAFF OF STATE AGENCIES
ARE NOT TRAINED SPECIFICALLY
IN DRAFTING REGULATIONS.
ESTABLISHING A CENTRALIZED
ENTITY
TO WRITE PROPOSED REGULATIONS
FOR STATE DEPARTMENTS WILL
REDUCE
MISINTERPRETATION AND ERRORS,
WHILE PROVIDING EASIER
COMPLIANCE
AND STREAMLINED ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO HELP THE
EXECUTIVE
BRANCH WITH THIS MEASURE.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE CHRIS
MICHELI,
WHO PROPOSED SUCH AN IDEA IN
AN ARTICLE THAT I READ ABOUT,
WHICH WAS THE IMPETUS FOR THIS
BILL.
AND MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS HERE TO
TESTIFY.
GOOD MORNING.
>> IS IT ON?
GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR CHRIS MCHALE, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE,
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE,
I THINK THE AUTHOR EXPRESSED THE
MAIN REASONS FOR
HAVING SUCH AN OFFICE OF
REGULATORY COUNSEL.
TWO QUESTIONS I KNOW THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED
INCLUDE WHY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE?
UM, WHILE WE HAVE A WHAT WE
CALL A PLURAL EXECUTIVE IN
A NUMBER OF INDEPENDENT
AGENCIES,
THOSE 200 PLUS, UH,
RULE MAKING ENTITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE PRIMARILY LINE AGENCIES,
MEANING THEY ARE REPORTABLE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
SO SORT OF LIKE WE HAVE GO-BIZ
AND THE OFFICE OF TRIBAL
ADVISOR.
IT'S MOST APPROPRIATE, SINCE
MOST REGULATIONS
ARE DRAFTED BY THOSE LINE
AGENCIES FOR THIS OFFICE TO BE
HOUSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS, IS,
YOU KNOW,
POTENTIAL FUNDING OR IMPACT
OF IT?
CANDIDLY, IT PROBABLY WOULDN'T
TAKE
MORE THAN A HANDFUL OF ATTORNEYS
TO DRAFT THOSE 5 TO 600
REGULATIONS
EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
AND HOPEFULLY WE WOULD HAVE THAT
CADRE OF
LAWYERS ALREADY IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
YOU COULD SIMPLY MOVE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS OVER
TO THAT OFFICE OF REGULATORY
COUNSEL.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
MICHAEL MILLER,
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS.
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF.
SIR NEIL HAS MADE A GOOD CASE
FOR WHY WE NEED THIS BILL.
AND I ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
CHRIS MICHELI.
IN SHORT, WHEN WE WORK WITH
AGENCIES ON REGULATIONS,
WE ALWAYS WANT REGULATIONS THAT
ARE CLEAR
ON THEIR FACE THAT ARE
UNDERSTANDABLE,
THAT DON'T CONFLICT WITH OTHER
LAWS AND THAT ARE WORKABLE,
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY WORK WITH AND MAKE
IT ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL OF THE
OF THE REGULATION.
ONE OF THEM WAS FRUSTRATING
EXPERIENCES
IS WHEN A REGULATION
IS PROPOSED AND THE AGENCY SAYS
IT DOES X, Y, Z.
AND THEN WE SIT DOWN WITH
LAWYERS
AND WE GET THE LAWYERS
WITH THEM AND THEY SAY, NO, IT
ACTUALLY DOES A,
B, C BECAUSE OF THESE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF LAW THAT
IT CONFLICTS WITH AND HOW IT ALL
FITS TOGETHER.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF YOU HAVE THIS
OFFICE CREATED BY THIS BILL,
THAT THOSE KINDS OF LEGAL ISSUES
CAN
BE RESOLVED BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THE
THE POLICY PROPOSED BY
REGULATION,
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW IT'S
DRAFTED,
WHAT IT DOES IN LAW,
AND HOW IT WORKS WITH OTHER
LAWS.
IMAGINE IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL.
SOMEONE COMES TO YOU WITH A BILL
IDEA AND YOU
DON'T HAVE THE LAWYERS TO WRITE
IT UP.
SO YOU WRITE IT UP YOURSELF.
YOU PUT IT IN THE PLACE OF LAW
THAT YOU THINK WORKS BEST,
AND THEN YOU GO TO COMMITTEE AND
YOU FIND OUT,
OH, ACTUALLY, IT CONFLICTS WITH
OTHER PROVISIONS OF THE LAW.
AND YOU LEARN THAT IN THE
COMMITTEE PROCESS.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS RIGHT NOW IS
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE LAWYERS
OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT
LAWYERS AND DON'T HAVE THE
INDEPENDENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SO MANY
CONFLICTING REGULATIONS THAT
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP ADDRESS AND AVOID.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
PLEASE.
>> MR.
CHAIR MEMBERS.
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK THE AUTHOR.
WE SEE THIS AS THE GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL OF 2024.
IT'S SO NEEDED.
AND WE SEE COST SAVINGS AT THE
END
OF THE DAY BECAUSE IF YOU CAN.
FORM INTERPRETATION OF LAW.
AND WRITING THIS, YOU'RE GOING
TO SAVE ALL THESE
ATTORNEYS AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
YOU'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY HAVE
A COST SAVINGS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DIDN'T YOU HEAR ME, DENNIS?
>> I'LL BE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
NOW, THAT'S THE WAY IT'S DONE.
>> WE SUPPORT.
YOU'RE A PRO.
WELL, HE.
OKAY.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT?
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL TURN IT BACK
TO,
UH, COMMITTEE HERE.
WELL, SENATOR WILK.
YEAH, I'D LOVE TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS.
SO IN A IN A PREVIOUS LIFE,
I RAN A TRADE ASSOCIATION
AND WE WORKED SO HARD TO GET THE
LEGISLATION PASSED.
AND THEN WHEN THE REGULATIONS
CAME OUT,
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
I ALSO THE CHANCELLOR OF MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
I USED TO BE A BOARD MEMBER OF.
SHE HAS A WHOLE POWERPOINT
PRESENTATION
ON CONFLICTING
REGULATIONS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
SO THEY DO ALL KINDS OF STUFF
THAT'S
IN VIOLATION OF OTHER
PROVISIONS.
AND IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY WE HAVEN'T
DONE THIS SOONER.
I GUESS IT TOOK A COMMON SENSE
CPA TO COME
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO CLEAN OUR
MESS UP.
SO AS WELL.
AS AS WELL AS PROFESSOR MICHELI.
AND SINCE I JUST FOUND OUT,
OBVIOUSLY MR.
WALKER DIDN'T READ ALL MY BILLS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
TOP
GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL OF THE
YEAR,
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO-AUTHOR
IF IT GETS AMENDED ALONG THE
WAY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE?
NO.
I THANK YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION
AND CLARIFICATION.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS, UM,
KIND OF FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR
POINT,
SENATOR WILK, WHY WASN'T THIS
DONE SOONER?
AND WHAT HAVE WE BEEN DOING?
WELL, I'M JUST A FRESHMAN,
RIGHT?
SO, SO WITH AND.
LAWYER WITHOUT.
HISTORY, I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WHEN I READ THIS IN A
NEWSLETTER THAT MR.
MICHELI HAD SEVERAL MONTHS AGO,
MY CHIEF OF STAFF AND I WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT AND WONDERING
THE VERY SAME THING.
IT IT REALLY MAKES COMPLETE
SENSE.
NOW, UM, THE GOVERNOR HAS SHOWN
A RETICENCE TO SIGN BILLS WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE KIND OF IS
DICTATING
TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
I, I'M HOPING HE DOESN'T VIEW
THIS THIS WAY,
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S MAKING
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH MORE
EFFICIENT
AND MORE EFFECTIVE, BOTH.
BUT I WOULD AGREE WITH THE
IMPLICATION OF
THE QUESTION AND WHAT SENATOR
WILK SAID.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THIS HASN'T
BEEN DONE BEFORE,
BUT WE CAN FIX IT.
ANYBODY ELSE.
SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
WHEN?
AND WE'LL VOTE WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM.
I ASK FOR AN EYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR.
AND MR.
CHAIR, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WILL YOU HAVE A BILL?
GREAT.
OR IS IT?
I DON'T.
>> GOOD MORNING.
OH SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER 16.
THAT'S SB 1088.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR ALVARADO
GIL.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR.
UM, I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL 1088.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH THE
RURAL
AND SMALL COMMUNITY FISH
RESILIENCE
PROGRAM WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THIS PROGRAM WILL WORK IN
COORDINATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES,
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD,
AND THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
DEVELOP A SYSTEM
FOR THE DISTRIBUTION OF STATE
MATCHING
FUNDS TO COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE
WILDLAND
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE OR
THE WUI.
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
IS IN LINE IS THE LINE AREA,
OR ZONE WHERE THE STRUCTURES
AND OTHER
HUMAN DEVELOPMENT MEET OR
INTERMINGLE
WITH UNDER UNDERDEVELOPED
WILDLAND
OR VEGETATIVE FUELS.
CALIFORNIA'S RURAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN GROUND
ZERO FOR LARGE SCALE
ENVIRONMENTAL
AND ECONOMIC DEVASTATION DURING
THE PAST
DECADE OR TWO DUE TO THESE
WILDFIRES.
AGING INFRASTRUCTURES COMBINED
WITH INSUFFICIENT RESOURCES
TO PREPARE FOR ADEQUATE WILDFIRE
RESPONSE,
HAS LEFT MANY OF THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES AT
RISK FOR FURTHER UNCHECKED FIRE
ACTIVITY.
COMMUNITIES IN THE TAHOE BASIN
IN MY
DISTRICT SERVE AS A PRIME
EXAMPLE,
WHERE MOST OF THE WATER SYSTEMS
WERE DEVELOPED BETWEEN
1930 TO 1950 TO SERVE ONLY
SEASONAL CABINS.
SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS OF THE
BASIN ARE STILL SERVED
BY A PATCHWORK OF SMALL AND
GEOGRAPHICALLY
ISOLATED WATER SYSTEMS THAT LACK
THE CAPACITY TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES.
SENATE BILL 1088 WOULD PROVIDE
MORE STATE
MATCHING FUNDS FOR WILDFIRE
DEFENSE,
IMPROVE OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE,
AND PROTECT OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JUSTIN BROGLIO WITH
THE NORTH TAHOE PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICT.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
JUSTIN BROGLIO, ON BEHALF OF
THE TAHOE
WATER FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION
PARTNERSHIP
AND THE NORTH TAHOE PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT,
I THINK, SENATOR, SENATE.
WELL, THIS BILL CREATES AN
AVENUE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
RURAL WATER PROVIDERS TO SEEK
MATCHING
FUNDS FOR CRITICAL WATER SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S IN THESE COMMUNITIES WHERE
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS,
AND OFTEN OUR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS,
TAKE ON THE FIREFIGHT WITH LOCAL
KNOWLEDGE AND LOCAL RESOURCES.
THOSE RESOURCES INCLUDE SMALL
MUNICIPAL WATER SUPPLIES.
IT'S IN THESE COMMUNITIES WHERE
OUR WATER PROVIDERS
ARE ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
CHALLENGED WITH OUTDATED,
UNDERSIZED AND UNDER BUILT WATER
SYSTEMS.
UM, IN CALIFORNIA, THERE ARE
NUMEROUS
PROGRAMS HELPING WUI COMMUNITIES
FUND
FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS AND
SUPPORTING
HOMEOWNERS WITH DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE NO SUCH
FUNDING
PROGRAMS FOR PROJECTS
THAT IMPROVE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION.
ADDITIONALLY, THE SMALL RATE
BASES OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE
TO FINANCE THESE PROJECTS WITH
RATES
ALONE AND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
UM, AND THEN SENATE BILL 28
WOULD ALSO ALLOW
WUI COMMUNITIES DESIGNATED IN
HIGH
AND VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES
TO SEEK THESE FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1088?
GOOD MORNING, STEVE WALSH, ON
BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TOWER ALLIANCE
HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND URGE
YOU,
URGE YOU TO VOTE, I THANK YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, DYLAN FINLEY,
ON BEHALF OF THE SIERRA
CONSORTIUM AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE.
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE WILL
VOTE.
BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
BECAUSE
WE ARE IN A DEFICIT YEAR.
SENATE BILL 1088 IS CONTINGENT
ON FUNDING BEING APPROPRIATED
PURSUANT TO A BOND MEASURE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
THE MEASURE IS SENATE BILL 867,
AUTHORED BY OUR COLLEAGUE IN
SANTA MONICA.
IN THAT BOND, THERE IS FUND
FUNDING
DEDICATED TO THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM.
SO MY BILL IS CODIFYING THIS
PROGRAM TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE STATE MATCHING
FUNDS.
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE, I WOULD
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT.
THAT WOULD BE SB 1325.
SENATOR BARRASSO.
OVER HERE.
THROUGH HERE.
GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
>> GREAT.
>> GET YOUR BREATH.
>> OKAY.
UH, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SB 1325 SIMPLIFIES THE PUBLIC
CONTRACTING
PROCESS FOR STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES
BY CREATING AN AUTHORIZING
STATUTE
FOR BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FREQUENTLY
AUTHORIZED
THE USE OF BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT,
BUT ON AN AD HOC BASIS FOR
SPECIFIC
ENTITIES AND CONTEXTS.
THIS CAUSES CONFUSION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
SOME AGENCIES HAVE EXPLICIT
PERMISSION TO UTILIZE
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT, WHILE
OTHERS DO NOT,
AND SOME HAVE AUTHORIZATION,
BUT ONLY
UNDER SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN OUR BUDGET SUB FIVE HEARING
LAST MONTH,
CALTRANS COMMENTED THEY REALLY
LIKED THE BEST VALUE METHOD.
IT ENSURES QUALITY OF THE
PRODUCT
AS WELL AS QUALITY OF THE JOBS.
THE AD HOC CONTRACTING
AUTHORITY,
WHICH IS OFTEN DONE IN VERY
DIFFERENT
SECTIONS OF STATE CODE,
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR AGENCIES
TO UNDERSTAND IF THEY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO ADOPT BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT MODELS.
SB 1325 EMPOWERS CITY STATES AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO USE OUR PUBLIC AUTHORITY,
OUR DOLLARS,
TO CREATE QUALITY PRODUCTS AND
QUALITY JOBS
WHILE ADVANCING EQUITY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
TODAY, I HAVE ELMAR LIZARDI FROM
THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION HERE TO
TESTIFY.
TO AN HOUR.
WAIT.
COULD YOU EXCUSE ME?
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW,
IF THAT'S OKAY.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
DODD.
>> HERE.
HERE.
WILKE.
PRESENT.
WILKE, PRESENT.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
HERE.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
HERE.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
BRADFORD.
GLASER.
JONES.
WIN.
HERE.
OKUBO.
SO ABOUT.
YOU'RE HERE.
>> OH, HERE.
SORRY, I TROBO HERE.
PADILLA HERE.
PORTANTINO HERE.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
PRESENT.
SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
HERE.
PERFECT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE SPEAKING NOW IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1325.
>> GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK.
MY NAME IS ELMER LAZARD.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION.
FIRST, WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
DURAZO FOR BRINGING FORTH
SB 1325 AND FOR CATALYZING MANY
OF THE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT LABOR STANDARDS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY
HAVING IN THE LEGISLATURE,
INCLUDING THIS ONE.
UM, THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
MAXIMIZING PUBLIC DOLLARS
BY MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
CREATE HIGH QUALITY,
GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT BENEFIT
OUR COMMUNITIES.
BY AUTHORIZING STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO UTILIZE
THE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
METHODS,
WE CAN ALLOW AGENCIES TO
ADDITIONALLY CONSIDER
IMPORTANT FACTORS SUCH AS
COMMUNITY BENEFITS,
LABOR AND WORKFORCE BENEFITS,
AND ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS TO
ASSESS
THE PROCUREMENT IMPACTS
MORE ACCURATELY AND TO ACHIEVE
MORE EQUITABLE
OUTCOMES IN THE BID PROCESS.
UM, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
BE
INVESTING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN CLIMATE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE JOBS THAT WE ARE CREATING
WITH
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE HIGH
QUALITY,
WELL-PAYING AND SAFE.
UM, WITHOUT ANY INTERVENTION,
WE RISK SPENDING THESE PUBLIC
DOLLARS ON LOW
WAGE AND DIRTY JOBS WITH
MEANINGFUL,
MINIMAL BENEFITS TO COMMUNITIES.
AND WHEN WE ONLY ALLOW FOR OTHER
BIDDING
OPTIONS LIKE LOWEST RESPONSIBLE
BIDDER,
WE OFTEN SEE THAT THIS IS THE
STATUS QUO.
UM, SITUATIONS WHERE COMPANIES
ARE COMPETING TO OFFER
THE CHEAPEST BIDS AT THE EXPENSE
OF WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES.
UM.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT WITHOUT CLEAR
AUTHORITY,
LIKE THE SENATOR HAS MENTIONED,
MANY AGENCIES ARE UNSURE WHETHER
THEY
CAN UTILIZE THIS METHODOLOGY.
AND THIS CONFUSION IS LIMITING
OUR AGENCIES,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE KNOW THAT
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
HAS ALREADY PROVEN TO
SUCCESSFULLY BENEFIT WORKERS
WHILE PRODUCING HIGH QUALITY
PRODUCTS.
BY SIMPLY GIVING AGENCIES THE
AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT WHEN
AWARDING CONTRACTS,
SB 1325 WILL HELP AGENCIES
ADVANCE EQUITY
ACROSS THE BOARD WHILE
MAXIMIZING
PUBLIC FUNDS AT A HISTORIC
MOMENT IN CLIMATE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT.
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT
AND WE URGE YOUR VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
>> CHRIS ROSE ON BEHALF OF NRDC
ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT?
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO COMMENT OR
QUESTION SENATOR CHOCOBO?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
OR MR.
CHAIR.
UM, A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON
THIS PARTICULAR
IS GREAT THAT YOU FOLKS WANT TO,
UM, INCLUDE, UM, UH,
BEST PRACTICES AND SO FORTH ON
ON THAT END.
NOW, IS THIS BILL IN LIEU OF
HAVING SEPARATE
BILLS WITH PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS,
INSTITUTING THIS IS JUST MAKING
THIS PRETTY MUCH A STANDARD IN,
UM, IN, IN THE STATE TO HAVE
LABOR, UM, BASED,
UH, COMPANIES BE ABLE TO BID
ON JOBS.
THE QUESTION I'LL LET YOU ANSWER
THAT,
AND THEN I'LL CONTINUE WITH MY
FOLLOWING QUESTION ON THAT.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THIS ONLY
ALLOWS STATE AGENCIES
TO USE THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT MODEL.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE.
AND BY ALLOWING IT THEN
THE AGENCIES KNOW THAT IF IT'S
BROUGHT BEFORE THEM AS A WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO DO,
THEN THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT,
BUT THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
DO IT.
AND WHAT THEY DO, THE LOCAL
AGENCIES DECIDE
WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENT FACTORS
THAT THEY WANT TO INCLUDE IN
DECIDING
WHO TO AWARD THE CONTRACT TO.
AND SO THEY HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO THE LOWEST
BIDDER
AS THE ONLY WAY THEY HAVE
OPTIONS.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO INCLUDE
MANY FACTORS QUALITY
OF THE OF THE PRODUCT, THE
QUALITY OF THE COMPANY.
THERE'S THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT THEY
COULD INCLUDE IN MAKING THAT
DECISION.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE JUST WANT TO
GIVE
THEM THE AUTHORITY THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO USE THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT
ON A STATE WIDE BASIS.
OKAY.
AND THEN I WAS KIND OF CURIOUS
IF THROUGH THE CHAIR,
IF I MAY ASK, UM,
A DEFINITION OF WHAT DIRTY JOBS
ENTAIL.
UM, IT WAS A, A DESCRIPTION
THAT WAS,
WAS GIVEN THAT IF WE DON'T
PURSUE
THIS PARTICULAR MODEL,
WE'RE SUBJECT TO DIRTY JOBS.
YOU WANT TO.
UH, SENATOR, I WAS SAYING THAT
IN OPPOSITION
TO THE CLEAN JOBS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN,
UM, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE STATE WANTING TO PUT
FORWARD.
I'M SORRY.
ONE MORE TIME.
YEAH, I WAS SAYING THAT IN, UM,
CONTRAST TO THE CLEAN JOBS THAT
THE STATE
HAS BEEN SAYING THAT THEY WANT
TO
MOVE FORWARD AND TO ADVOCATE
FOR.
OKAY.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ANY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS?
SENATOR RUBIO?
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
UM, I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, AS
A LOCAL COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR MANY YEARS, I, YOU
KNOW,
WE WERE CAUGHT SOMETIMES TRYING
TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WAS BEST FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
UM, FOR EXAMPLE, SOMETIMES WE'VE
HAD COMPANIES THAT WERE
FROM THE COMMUNITY THAT LIVED
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THE JOBS WERE FROM OUR
COMMUNITY,
BUT WE COULDN'T NECESSARILY PICK
THAT PARTICULAR COMPANY BECAUSE
IT WASN'T THE LOWEST BID.
BUT YET, SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO
HIRE WITHIN.
TO ME, IT'S ABOUT GIVING
OPTIONS,
NOT NECESSARILY MANDATING,
BUT THAT SHOULD BE UP TO THAT
COMMUNITY
TO DECIDE IF THEY CAN BRING MORE
VALUE,
LIKE LOCAL HIRE AND JUST OTHER
THINGS THAT
REALLY HELP A COMMUNITY, UH,
MOVE FORWARD.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GIVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOW
AT LEAST GIVE CLARITY IN TERMS
OF WHAT THEY CAN DO.
AND AGAIN, I KNOW THAT THERE'S
WAYS
OF BRINGING SO MUCH LOCAL VALUE
IN TERMS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS,
IN TERMS OF LOCAL HIRE
PROVISIONS.
I MEAN, THERE'S SO MUCH WE CAN
DO.
AND I THINK THAT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS,
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE SOMETIMES
AS LOCAL ELECTEDS
OR STATE ELECTEDS HANDS ARE TIED
IN TERMS
OF WHAT YOU CAN PICK BASED ON
THE VALUE.
SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE, I'LL MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, I AGREE WITH, UH, MY
COLLEAGUE, UM, RUBIO.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL.
I THINK IN THIS MOMENT TO HAVE
REALLY
TOUGH FINANCE AND BUDGETING,
BOTH LOCAL COUNTY, UM, AND STATE
AGENCIES,
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE OPTIONS TO
FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN USE DOLLARS,
PARTICULARLY PUBLIC DOLLARS, AS
MULTIPLIERS.
UM, THIS OPTION ALLOWS A
JURISDICTION TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE NEEDS AND TO BE
VERY SPECIFIC.
I REMEMBER, UM, WORKING IN
COMMUNITY WHERE
WE WERE REDEVELOPING A HOSPITAL
AND THINKING ABOUT THE MODEL
FOR, FOR,
FOR WHAT THAT COULD LOOK LIKE.
AND ONE OF THE, UM, UH,
ONE OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
HAD BEEN PART OF DEVELOPING A
HOSPITAL MAYBE 5 OR
10 YEARS BEFORE THAT TALKED
ABOUT HOW WHEN HE DROVE
THROUGH THE PARKING LOT OF THAT
CONSTRUCTION SITE,
THEY WERE ALL NEVADA AND
ARIZONA, UH,
LICENSE PLATES ON THOSE VEHICLES
WHO WERE
DOING THAT WORK AND WHAT IT
FELT LIKE
TO BE A CONSTRUCTION WORKER
IN L.A.
COUNTY AND NOT BE ABLE TO TO
BUILD THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE
OUT OF STATE FOLKS WERE ACTUALLY
BUILDING THE HOSPITAL.
SO I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD
TO MOVING THE BILL WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT,
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE TIME IS
RIGHT.
>> MR.
CHAIR.
THE TIME IS RIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO HAS ALREADY
REQUESTED THAT.
SO I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
BUT APPRECIATE YOU NEVERTHELESS.
CLOSE SECOND.
UH, BUT I WANT TO LET THE
AUTHOR, UH, CLOSE I.
I APPRECIATE ALL OF THE COMMENTS
AND I HOPE I ANSWERED
YOUR QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
OKAY.
UH, SO WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB 1325 MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
DODD I DODD I.
WILK.
NO.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
HI.
ALVARADO.
GIL I.
ARCHULETA.
ASHBY.
BRADFORD.
GLAZER.
JONES.
NGUYEN.
NO.
OKUBO.
PADILLA I.
PADILLA I PORTENTINO I
FLORENTINO I.
ROTH.
RUBIO I RUBIO I.
SATO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I.
TO THREE.
6 TO 3.
UH, WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
AND, UH, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
SO WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE,
SB 1220, SENATOR LIMON.
>> ARE YOU BACK?
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND SENATORS,
I WANT TO.
NOPE.
NOT YET.
BEFORE YOU STARTED, WE WANT TO
REMIND
THE MEMBERS THAT THE ANALYSIS
YOU HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU REFLECTS THE
AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO.
YOU SHOULD ALL HAVE A COPY, BUT
JUST IN CASE COPIES
ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED WITH THAT
SENATOR,
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
AND I DO WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
AMENDED.
THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT THE
QUALITY OF PUBLIC
SERVICES BY REQUIRING HUMAN
WORKERS TO REMAIN
IN CALL CENTERS FOR GOVERNMENT
BENEFIT PROGRAMS,
INSTEAD OF BEING OUTSOURCED
BY I.
THESE CALL CENTERS SERVE OUR
MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS,
ENROLLING IN PROGRAMS LIKE
CALWORKS,
MEDI-CAL, HEALTHY FAMILIES, AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA.
WHEN PEOPLE ENROLLING IN THESE
PROGRAMS RUN INTO BARRIERS,
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO SIGN UP,
WHICH IS WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
HAVING INDIVIDUALS
AT CALL CENTERS IS ESSENTIAL
TO CONNECTING RESIDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY
TO CRITICAL SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT
THERE
IS NO THAT THERE IS HUMAN
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE WHEN PEOPLE
CALL TO RECEIVE HELP.
OUR INTENT IS NOT TO PRECLUDE
AI FROM
BEING USED AS A TOOL TO ASSIST.
FINDING THE PERFECT LINE BETWEEN
PROTECTING WORKERS AND NOT
STIFLING INNOVATION TAKES SOME
WORK AND CONVERSATIONS,
AND I COMMIT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
TO FIND THE RIGHT DEFINITION OF
CORE JOB FUNCTION.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT,
I HAVE YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH
THE LABOR FEDERATION AND
KIMBERLY
ROSENBERG WITH SEIU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR DODD AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE,
YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION,
CO-SPONSOR OF SB 1220,
A BILL THAT WILL PROTECT CALL
CENTER WORKERS
AND THE PUBLIC BY PUTTING
GUARDRAILS
ON THE USE OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE
AT PUBLIC CALL CENTERS.
THE EXPONENTIAL GROWTH OF AI
WILL IMPACT EVERY
INDUSTRY AND WORKER ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AI CAN BE A VERY PRODUCTIVE TOOL
WHEN USED TO SUPPORT WORKERS,
NOT WHEN IT'S USED TO REPLACE,
CONTROL, OR ELIMINATE THEIR JOBS
WITHOUT
WORKER CENTERED GUARDRAILS PUT
IN PLACE.
I CAN UNFORTUNATELY BE USED TO
EXPLOIT
DE-SKILL AND REPLACE WORKERS,
HARMING NOT ONLY THE WORKERS
OF THE STATE,
BUT ALSO RESIDENTS OVERALL.
SB 1220 DOES NOT BAN THE USE
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE,
BUT RATHER ENSURES WORKERS ARE
TRULY AT THE CENTER
OF THE PROCUREMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT
OF AI IN THE WORKPLACE,
AS AMENDED AS THE SENATOR
REFERENCED.
SB 1220 HAS TWO MAIN PROVISIONS.
FIRST, SB 1220 PROHIBITS THE
STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
OUTSOURCING PUBLIC BENEFIT CALL
CENTER JOBS TO FIRMS USING
AI TO ELIMINATE THE ESSENTIAL
CORE JOB FUNCTION
OF PUBLIC BENEFIT WORKERS UNDER
THE BILL,
AS REFERENCED BY THE SENATOR.
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS INCLUDE
THOSE SUCH AS CALWORKS,
CALFRESH, EDD, MEDI-CAL,
AND ALSO 211 AND NINE EIGHT
MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ESSENTIALLY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS WHO SHOULDN'T
ONLY HAVE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO AN AI SYSTEM.
SECOND, SB 1220 REQUIRES AN
IMPACT
ASSESSMENT REPORT BY BE PRODUCED
BY AN AGENCY THAT UTILIZES AI
TO SUPPORT
THEIR CALL CENTER WORKERS.
THE REPORT IS INTENDED TO
INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY FOR WORKERS,
AND WOULD INCLUDE INFORMATION
SUCH AS ALL
THE INTENDED USES OF THE AI
SYSTEM,
AND IT IS CLOSURE OF THE DATA
USED TO PRODUCE
THE OUTCOMES FROM THAT SYSTEM.
SB 1220 CREATES GUARDRAILS FOR
WORKERS AND ENSURE AI IS USED
AS A TOOL FOR CALL CENTER
WORKERS
TO INCREASE EFFICIENCY,
PRODUCTIVITY, AND EFFECTIVENESS
WHEN
RESPONDING TO CALLERS AND
SUPPORT.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AI VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER
WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR SB 1220.
CALL CENTRES ARE A RESOURCE FOR
THOSE THAT
HAVE ALREADY HIT THEIR BREAKING
POINT,
WHETHER IT'S DIFFICULTY
NAVIGATING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY
OR THOSE FOR A MYRIAD OF REASONS
AGE,
LANGUAGE BARRIERS THAT CANNOT
USE ONLINE SERVICES.
SO THEY'RE LOOKING FOR A HUMAN
TOUCH.
WE BELIEVE THESE ARE THE CENTERS
THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
HUMAN
AVAILABLE THAT HAS EMPATHY,
THAT CAN NAVIGATE THOSE NUANCES,
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE PRIORITIZING
THOSE PROTECTIONS.
FURTHER.
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE HEART
OF AB 12 AB 2508,
WHICH WAS PASSED IN 2012.
IT'S JUST EXPANDING IT TO TAKE
INTO
CONSIDERATION MODERN TECHNOLOGY.
THERE IS A ROLE FOR TECHNOLOGY
IN AI,
BUT WITHOUT WORKERS,
WE HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND THAT ITS
ROLLOUT CAN BE A DISASTER.
FOR INSTANCE, CAL SOARS WHEN
IT WAS FIRST ROLLED OUT,
WAS A CRISIS IN COUNTIES.
WE SAW DELAYS, PEOPLE BEING
DROPPED FROM SERVICES,
CASELOADS THAT USUALLY TOOK
A DAY TRIPLING, QUADRUPLING.
UM.
BECAUSE THERE WAS LITTLE WORKER
ENGAGEMENT.
THROUGH WORKER ENGAGEMENT AND
DIRECT INTERACTION,
WE HAVE HELPED TURN AROUND AND
NOW IT'S BEING
EXPANDED TO EVERY COUNTY IN THE
STATE.
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
A BALANCE THAT CAN BE MET THERE,
AND WE THINK THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT.
WE WANT TO SEE TECHNOLOGY HELP
REDUCE CASELOADS WHILE
RETAINING THE HEART OF OUR
SERVICES AND OUR CENTERS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT?
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS.
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA,
DISTRICT NINE, WHICH COVERS
CALIFORNIA,
NEVADA AND HAWAII,
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THE LANGUAGE GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING SAMANTHA GORDON
WITH TECH
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL, PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE
AND SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
I AM SENATOR WILK.
YEAH, I'VE GOT A COMMENT.
I KNOW IN THE ANALYSIS IT TALKS
ABOUT
THIS MIGHT ADD ADDITIONAL COSTS,
BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, IT'S
WELL WORTH IT.
I'M OLD, SO I JUST RECENTLY
FILED
FOR MY FEDERAL PENSION.
AS YOU KNOW, WE DON'T GET ONE
HERE.
UM, AND I WAS DREADING IT.
RIGHT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, I GOT A
PERSON RIGHT AWAY,
NAVIGATED ME THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND WAS ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S ONE OF OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO OUR
CITIZENS IS TO MAKE IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE.
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
I WAS JUST GOING TO SHARE THE
SAME THING.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
HUMAN BEINGS BEHIND
THE PHONE WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
SUCH IMPORTANT DECISIONS.
AND ESPECIALLY, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE ARE CALLING DISTRESSED
ALREADY.
UM, SO I WAS JUST GOING TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE.
SENATOR COBO.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LEHMAN.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
SO I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
FOR CLARITY PURPOSES.
UM, I WAS READING THE THE BILL,
AND THOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE
COMPONENT OF THE HUMAN,
UH, TOUCH, PER SE, UM, I'M A
PEOPLE PERSON,
SO I HATE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WHEN I HAVE THESE, UM,
COMPUTER,
YOU KNOW, VOICE MESSAGES
ANSWERING THE PHONE.
BUT, UM, HOW WOULD THIS PLAY OUT
IF THIS WERE TO MOVE FORWARD?
HOW WOULD THIS PLAY OUT IN
INSTANCES SUCH AS.
BECAUSE I'M THINKING OF THE FACT
THAT WE WENT
THROUGH THE EDD SCENARIO DURING
THE PANDEMIC,
WHERE IT WAS COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED.
WE DID NOT HAVE THE HUMAN, UH,
PERSONNEL OF WORKFORCE TO BE
ABLE TO
MEET THE DEMANDS THAT WERE ON
EDD,
AND THE SYSTEM BASICALLY BROKE.
AND I'M THINKING IF WE HAD HAD
A,
UH, THE ASSISTANCE OF AI PER SE,
TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER AND DIRECT
THESE CALLS,
UH, SOMEWHAT, IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ACTUALLY BENEFICIAL.
SO HOW WOULD THIS PLAY FOR IN
CASE OF EMERGENCIES
OR IN CASE OF A DEMAND OR IN
AGENCIES THAT WE JUST DO NOT
HAVE
THE WORKFORCE IN PLACE AS WE
DO IN MANY,
IN MANY SPACES WITHIN OUR THE,
WITHIN THE,
WITHIN THE STATE DEPARTMENTS.
AND IF.
APPROPRIATE, WITH THE CHAIR.
I'M GOING TO ACTUALLY HAVE OUR
SPONSORS ANSWER THAT.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR.
SO WITHIN THIS CURRENT, UH,
LIKE THIS IS IN THE CONTRACT
CODE,
THERE ARE CLAUSES WITHIN THIS
CODE SECTION THAT WE ARE
AMENDING THAT ALLOWS FOR THESE
EXACT SCENARIOS,
FOR EMERGENCY DISASTERS TO
PRECLUDE ANY, UM,
INSTANCES WHERE OUTSOURCING MAY
NOT BE ALLOWED OR AVAILABLE.
SO IF THERE IS AN EMERGENCY,
THIS WOULD BE ALLOWED.
SO ONLY DURING EMERGENCIES,
NOT WHEN WE HAVE SHORTFALLS OF
WORKFORCE.
UH, WE IT'S CLASSIFIED AS
EMERGENCIES.
SO THAT WOULD KIND OF BE
DEPENDENT ON,
ON WHAT'S CLASSIFIED AS THAT
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE?
SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
UH, MEMBERS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION, UM, ON SB
1220.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR RUBIO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED,
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I I WILK I WILK I ALVARADO GIL
I ALVARADO.
GIL I ARCHULETA.
ASHBY BRADFORD A BRADFORD I
GLAZER.
JONES.
GWYN.
OKOBO.
HADIYA.
HADIYA I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I ROTH.
RUBIO.
I RUBIO I SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SO WE HAVE SEVEN VOTES AND WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR PADILLA, YOU'VE GOT A
COUPLE OF BILLS,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A
WITNESS
THAT'S READY TO GET ON THE ROAD.
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE WHICHEVER
BILL
THAT PERSON IS TESTIFYING ON.
IT'S FINE WITH ME.
WHICH BILL IS THAT?
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION, I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT SB 893.
TAKE 14.
ITEM 14, FILE ITEM 14.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
SIR.
MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE,
I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT SB 893,
THE CALIFORNIA AI RESEARCH HUB.
BEGIN BY THANKING THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
SB 893 WOULD REQUIRE GOV OPS
AND THE GOV AND GO-BIZ AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
TO COLLABORATE WITH ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
IN ESTABLISHING
THE CALIFORNIA ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE RESEARCH HUB.
THE AI RESEARCH HUB WOULD
FURTHER
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT,
DEPLOYMENT AND THE APPLICATION
OF AI TECHNOLOGY
FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD BY
FACILITATING
ACCESS TO COMPUTING
RESOURCES AND DATA FOR ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS,
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AND
INTERESTS,
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
AS WE'VE HEARD MANY TIMES IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I'LL EMPHASIZE HERE AGAIN,
THE TREMENDOUS IMPACT THAT AI
WILL HAVE AS A TOOL,
AND IT STANDS TO CHANGE OUR
WORLD IN WAYS WE HAVEN'T
SEEN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
INTERNET AGE.
AT THE SAME TIME, IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT AROUND
AI BE GUIDED BY STRONG
PRINCIPLES
AND GUARDRAILS AND PROTECT
PRIVACY,
ADVANCED SECURITY, AND ADDRESS
RISKS
AND POTENTIAL HARMS TO SOCIETY.
TODAY, PRIVATE ENTITIES
AND PORTFOLIOS SUCH AS GOOGLE,
MICROSOFT AND META HAVE LED THE
RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT SPACE IN AI
TECHNOLOGY,
AND THIS IS IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE
THIS DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY REQUIRES VAST AMOUNTS
OF RESOURCES AND CAPITAL,
NOT TO MENTION CAPACITY IN A
TECHNOLOGICAL SENSE,
BY DEFAULT,
THE INNOVATIVE DEVELOPMENT AND
DISCUSSION
IN THIS SPACE IS DOMINATED BY
FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES
THAT
OWN THE MAJORITY OF THIS
PORTFOLIO.
AND I DO NOT INSINUATE HERE THAT
THAT'S A BAD THING.
I SIMPLY, AS IS REFLECTED IN
THIS BILL,
PROPOSE THAT SOMETHING IS
MISSING.
THERE IS NO WAY TO MATCH THIS
FINANCIAL
MIGHT THAT THESE ENTITIES
HAVE ON THE FRONTIER AND
DOMINATING
THIS SPACE ALONE.
OUR STATE, CALIFORNIA, HAS THE
WORLD'S PREMIER
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING,
LED BY SOME OF THE GREATEST
MINDS IN THIS FIELD.
THEIR TALENT IS FORMIDABLE.
UH, AND CAN YOU IMAGINE IF IT
WERE PROPERLY
HARNESSED AND INTEGRATED INTO
THIS SPACE?
CALIFORNIA, WITH OUR VAST
NETWORK OF INSTITUTIONS
GENERATING RESEARCH FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD,
CAN BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
DEVELOPMENT
AND RESEARCH OF AI TECHNOLOGIES
AND ENSURE THAT WE MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS
FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD.
WE ALSO HAVE A MARKET ADVANTAGE
AS
THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD,
AND WE CAN USE THIS MARKET
POSITION
AND POWER TO INFLUENCE THIS
MARKET TO
HELP LEAD IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF ETHICAL
AND RESPONSIBLE AI TECHNOLOGY
THAT
CENTERS THE PUBLIC INTEREST BY
ADDRESSING
THE GAP IN COMPUTING RESOURCES,
FACILITATING ACCESS TO DATA,
AND HARNESSING THE POWER OF
OUR WORLD
CLASS NETWORK OF RESEARCH
INSTITUTES.
AS WE CAN'T AFFORD TO CEDE THIS
SPACE TO OTHER STATES,
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LET THIS
SPACE REMAIN UN DEMOCRATIZED,
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE HUB,
TO BLEND OUR ECONOMIC TALENT,
OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST VOICES IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST
WITH SOME OF THE LEADING EDGE
PRIVATE
SECTOR PIONEERS IN THIS SPACE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT
OF THIS RESEARCH
HUB WOULD DO WITH ME TODAY IS
RUSSELL WALD,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE STANFORD
INSTITUTE FOR
HUMAN CENTERED ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU.
SENATORS, I COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 893,
THE CALIFORNIA INTELLIGENCE
RESEARCH HUB.
MUCH OF THE FOUNDATIONAL WORK
THAT HAS LED US
TO THIS MOMENT IN AI CAME FROM
ACADEMIA.
IN FACT, 82% OF ALGORITHMS IN
USE TODAY
ORIGINATED FROM UNIVERSITIES
AND NONPROFIT GROUPS SUPPORTED
BY GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
HISTORICALLY, ACADEMIC RESEARCH
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH GOVERNMENT
HAS ANCHORED THE AMERICAN
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM.
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENT OFTEN
REQUIRES
INVESTMENT IN LONG TERME
RESEARCH THAT MAY TAKE DECADES
TO
SHOW ANY COMMERCIAL POTENTIAL.
HOWEVER, WITH SOME GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT,
UNIVERSITIES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ENGAGE
IN HIGH RISK RESEARCH THAT IN
THE LONG RUN,
YIELDS WORLD CHANGING RESULTS.
INDEED, MANY TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES THAT
ARE NOW CRITICAL TO LIFE, SUCH
AS GPS,
MRIS AND EVEN THE INTERNET CAN
TRACE THEIR ORIGIN STORIES
BACK TO RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE
UNDER THIS MODEL.
UNIVERSITY RESEARCH IS CURIOSITY
DRIVEN AND PURSUED
WITH THE LONG TERME INTEREST OF
SOCIETY IN MIND,
MEANING THAT THERE IS A STRONG
RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT THE GOVERNMENT
MAKES,
THAT THE GOVERNMENT MAKES INTO
ACADEMIC RESEARCH.
HOWEVER, SIGNIFICANT
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES
IN AI HAS CREATED A FUNDAMENTAL
SHIFT IN WHERE RESEARCH INTO
THE FRONTIER
AI TECHNOLOGY IS OCCURRING.
RESEARCH INTO THE LATEST AI
MODELS
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN COMPUTE POWER AND ACCESS TO
QUALITY DATA SETS,
WHICH AT THE MOMENT ONLY PRIVATE
COMPANIES
POSSESS THESE RESOURCES.
WHILE INDUSTRY RESEARCH IS
IMPORTANT,
THAT IS JUST ONE NEEDED
PERSPECTIVE.
ADDRESSING THE RESOURCE GAP IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING WE MAKE
HOLISTIC ADVANCEMENTS IN AI THAT
BENEFIT SOCIETY AT LARGE.
IN THE CASE OF AI, ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF DATA
ARE NECESSARY TO PROPERLY TRAIN
MODELS,
AND GOVERNMENT DATA CAN BE
ENORMOUSLY
BENEFICIAL IN THAT TRAINING,
PARTICULARLY IN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES
SUCH AS HEALTH CARE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS OUTSIZED
EQUITIES IN.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS A STRONG
BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR A NATIONAL AI
RESEARCH RESOURCE,
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE BOTH
COMPUTATIONAL
RESOURCES AND ACCESS
TO GOVERNMENT DATA SETS FOR
UNIVERSITY RESEARCH.
WHILE WE'RE EXCITED BY THE
EFFORTS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL,
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT AI RESEARCH
WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM GOVERNMENT
AT ALL LEVELS,
TAKING STEPS TO SUPPORT THESE
RESOURCES.
THERE ARE FEW PLACES BETTER
EQUIPPED
TO DO THIS THAN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO
SPEARHEAD THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ETHICAL
AND RESPONSIBLE AI TECHNOLOGIES
THAT
PRIORITIZE THE PUBLIC'S
INTEREST.
AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON AI
LAST YEAR ARTICULATED CALIFORNIA
ALREADY
HAS MANY PIECES IN PLACE WHICH
WILL
MAKE IT A LEADER IN AI
DEVELOPMENT.
IN ADDITION TO HAVING OVER 80%
OF
THE TOP AI COMPANIES BASED IN
THE STATE,
CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES SERVE AS KEY
PILLARS
OF THE TO THE POWERFUL RESEARCH
AND INNOVATION
ECOSYSTEM THAT EXISTS HERE.
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES HAVE
ALWAYS PLAYED AN ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES,
INCLUDING IN THE FIELDS OF DEEP
LEARNING
AND OTHER FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES THAT
HAVE MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR AI
TO DEVELOP
TO WHERE WE WHERE IT IS TODAY.
IT IS ONLY FITTING THAT
CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS PLAY
A LEADING ROLE IN CREATING THE
NEXT
CHAPTER OF AI DEVELOPMENT.
FOR THIS REASON, STANFORD IS
SUPPORTIVE OF SB 893 WITH
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS FROM THE
STATE GOVERNMENT,
INCLUDING PROVIDING COMPUTE
POWER
AND GREATER ACCESS TO STATE
DATA,
CALIFORNIA IS WELL POSITIONED TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING
INSTITUTIONS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
TO
CREATE A STRONG PUBLIC RESEARCH
RESOURCE
AND CEMENT ITS LEADERSHIP IN AI
DEVELOPMENT.
PUBLIC INVESTMENT INTO AI
RESEARCH
IN CALIFORNIA WILL SERVE AS
A CATALYST FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF
RESPONSIBLE AI AROUND THE GLOBE,
AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT THE
COMMITTEE
WILL MOVE THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD.
THANK YOU, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
>> MORNING, MR.
CHAIR.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY.
YES, SIR.
MR.
CHAIR.
YOU ALREADY KNEW.
THAT I.
DID.
YES.
MR.
CHAIR, CHRIS MCHALE,
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
NAOMI PADRONA.
>> ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS
AND WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
>> THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN DODD.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MARIO
GUERRERO,
ON BEHALF OF THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO
AT THE COMMITTEE?
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
HE WANTS TO MOVE THE BILL.
BUT I HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS.
SENATOR RUBIO.
YEAH, WELL THANK YOU.
I REALLY DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT CLEARLY WE
AS A SOCIETY IN THE WORLD,
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH.
AND IT'S, I BELIEVE,
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
WE CAN DO RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE GET AHEAD OF THIS
SITUATION.
I THINK THAT THERE'S GREAT
OPPORTUNITY
FOR ADVANCEMENTS.
I MEAN, WE'VE SEEN, LIKE WITH
JUST TECHNOLOGY IN GENERAL,
HOW MUCH IT'S HELPED US IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
HOWEVER, IT REALLY POSES
A RISK IF IT GOES UNCHECKED.
AND IF WE DON'T, UH, INVEST,
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
I JUST READ AN ARTICLE FROM THE
NEW YORK
TIMES THIS MORNING THAT
DISCUSSES,
AND I THINK THE TITLE IS TEEN
GIRLS CONFRONT, UH,
AN EPIDEMIC OF FAKE NEWS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AND NOW THAT IS THE LATEST WAY
THAT, YOU KNOW,
WOMEN AND VICTIMS, PER SE ARE
BEING BULLIED ON CAMPUS.
I MEAN, THERE'S SO MUCH TO
LEARN.
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS THE ONE
AREA WHERE WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO JUST LET IT
BE UNCHECKED.
AND AND SO I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO CENTRALIZE IT,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF CREATING
AN AI RESEARCH HUB.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE
THAT WE DON'T LET THIS GET AWAY
FROM US.
I KNOW SOCIAL MEDIA STARTED MANY
YEARS AGO,
AND NOW WE'RE KIND OF SEEING
HOW FAR IT'S
GONE IN TERMS OF IMPACTING OUR
LIVES.
PERSONALLY, I WAS TALK I HAD A
SENIOR SCAM
STOPPER EVENT IN MY DISTRICT,
AND I MEAN,
THE SENIORS ARE BEING CALLED BY
THEIR GRANDCHILDREN
CRYING FROM JAIL, GIVE ME MONEY.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST REALLY
INTERESTING HOW, YOU KNOW,
YOU DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE IT'S
NOT YOUR FAMILY ON THE LINE.
AND THEY'RE JUST SCAMMING THESE
INDIVIDUALS
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND OUR SENIORS AND OUR, OUR
MOST VULNERABLE ARE,
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO
SUFFER
THE CONSEQUENCE IF WE DON'T
INVEST.
SO IT IS EXPENSIVE.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT, UH, YOU
KNOW,
I BELIEVE IT'S WORTH THE
INVESTMENT.
AND SO I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR IT.
I NOT ONLY DO I WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL,
BUT I WANT TO CO-AUTHOR THIS
BILL.
AND I HOPE THAT WE GET TO A
POINT WHERE WE DO
HAVE ALL THE DATA WE NEED IN
FRONT OF US SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE BETTER POLICY
DECISIONS BASED
ON INFORMATION THAT WE'VE
RESEARCHED.
SO THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT, I THINK, UH,
THE SENATOR MOVED THE BILL,
BUT I'LL ADD AS A CO-AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO COMMENT?
QUESTIONS?
SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
SENATOR?
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
OKAY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I DODD I WILK I WILK I
ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO.
GIL I ARCHULETA.
ASHBY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I.
GLAZER.
JONES.
NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I.
OKUBO.
OKUBO I.
PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO.
FLORENTINO I.
ROTH.
RUBIO I.
CIARDO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
WE'LL MOVE BACK IN THE ORDER
AND MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER 13,
SB 892.
WHERE'S THAT ON?
YES.
YES, SIR.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, I WANT
TO THANK YOU
AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MINE,
AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
SB 892 REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY TO DEVELOP
AND ADOPT REGULATIONS TO CREATE
AN ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENT RISK
MANAGEMENT STANDARD AND REQUIRE
A RISK MANAGEMENT STANDARD
TO INCLUDE A DETAILED RISK
ANALYSIS
ASSESSMENT PROCEDURE.
EXCUSE ME FOR PROCURING
AUTOMATED DECISION
SYSTEMS OR ADDS ANALYZE SPECIFIC
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE ADDS
METHODS
FOR APPROPRIATE RISK CONTROLS,
AND EXAMINE ADVERSE INCIDENT
MONITORING PROCEDURES.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT IT IT DOES THREE THINGS.
FIRST, IT WOULD ASSESS THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED
WITH PROCURING HIGH RISK, I
ADDS,
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS THAT HAVE
A HIGH
IMPACT ON INDIVIDUALS RIGHTS,
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
HEALTH, EDUCATION,
EMPLOYMENT, INSURANCE,
UTILITIES,
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, PUBLIC
SERVICES,
AND JUSTICE OR LEGAL SERVICES.
SECOND, IT REQUIRES THE
DEVELOPMENT AND ADOPTION OF
A RISK MANAGEMENT STANDARD THAT
INCLUDES ASSESSMENT,
APPROPRIATE RISK CONTROLS AND
ADVERSE INCIDENT
MONITORING WHEN PROCURING SUCH
SYSTEMS.
AND THIRD, IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE ENGAGEMENT AND CONSULTATION
WITH THE DIVERSITY OF
STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING THOSE MOST AFFECTED BY
GOVERNMENT USE OF THESE SYSTEMS,
SUCH AS PUBLIC TRUST AND SAFETY
EXPERTS,
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS,
CIVIL SOCIETY GROUPS,
WORKERS AND ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS.
AI TECHNOLOGY THAT IS PROCURED
AND DEPLOYED RESPONSIBLY
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVOLUTIONIZE
NOT JUST HOW WE ADMINISTER
GOVERNMENT SERVICES,
BUT OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY.
THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN ALSO POSE,
HOWEVER,
SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO SAFETY,
PRIVACY AND CIVIL RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S USED TO
ASSIST
OR REPLACE HUMAN DECISION MAKING
IN CRITICAL SECTORS SUCH AS
HOUSING,
EMPLOYMENT AND HEALTH CARE.
AS THESE APPLICATIONS OF THESE
SYSTEMS WILL BE VARIED,
THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
SUBSEQUENT
RISK CONTROLS MUST BE TAILORED
AND MUST BE UNIQUE TO THE
TECHNOLOGY IN QUESTION.
THIS STEP IS CRITICAL STEP AS
WE DETERMINE WHAT AI PRODUCTS
ARE SAFE FOR GOVERNMENT
PROCUREMENT AND DEPLOYMENT.
NOT ONLY WILL THIS STRICT
SCRUTINY
PROTECT THE STATE FROM
LIABILITY,
BUT IT WILL ALSO HELP ASSURE
THE PUBLIC
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE ARE
ACQUIRING ON THEIR BEHALF HAS
BEEN
ASSESSED WITH SAFETY IN MIND.
INDEED, WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT
THESE RISK ASSESSMENT TESTS
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND ISSUES
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY,
WHICH HAVE ALREADY OCCURRED
IN 2022,
THE LAO FOUND THAT CALIFORNIA
ED,
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT,
PROCURED AN AUTOMATED REVIEW
SOFTWARE THAT FLAGGED 1.1
MILLION CLAIMS AS FRAUDULENT,
MEANING WORKERS STOPPED
RECEIVING THEIR BENEFITS
AT A CRITICAL TIME TO THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
ULTIMATELY, MORE THAN HALF OF
THOSE CLAIMS,
OVER 600,000, WERE CONFIRMED AS
LEGITIMATE.
THE HARDSHIP THAT THESE
ERRONEOUS
FINDINGS CREATED COULD
HAVE BEEN FORESEEN AND AVOIDED
THROUGH PROPER RISK
ASSESSMENT BEFORE IT WAS GRANTED
ACCESS TO CONTROL,
A LIFELINE THAT MILLIONS OF
FAMILIES DEPENDED UPON.
BY ENACTING THESE SAFEGUARDS
PROPOSED BY SB 892,
CALIFORNIA CAN SET A NATIONAL
STANDARD
THAT DRIVES INNOVATION OF
AI TECHNOLOGY AND SERVICES WHILE
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
FROM RISKS POSED BY AUTOMATED
DECISION MAKING SYSTEMS.
WITH ME TODAY IS SAMANTHA GORDON
FROM
THE TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN DODD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT SB 892 AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF SETTING STANDARDS
FOR PUBLIC SECTOR PROCUREMENT
OF AI SYSTEMS.
AS THE SENATOR SAID, I'M
SAMANTHA GORDON,
I'M THE CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER
AT TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE.
OUR MISSION IS TO RAISE PUBLIC
CONSCIOUSNESS
ABOUT ECONOMIC EQUITY
ISSUES IN THE TECH INDUSTRY'S
PRODUCTS AND PRACTICES,
AND ENSURE TECHNOLOGY'S GROWTH
BENEFITS EVERYONE.
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB 892 IN
THIS COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT AS
CALIFORNIA LOOKS TO ADOPT AI
SYSTEMS
AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGY,
WE CAN BUILD A CLEAR SET OF
STANDARDS THAT CAN BENEFIT
ALL CALIFORNIANS IN ORDER TO
MAKE THE MOST
OF THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES PRESENT
AND SPUR INNOVATION IN OUR
STATE'S SERVICES,
WE MUST FIRST ENSURE THAT WE
PLACE COMMON SENSE
GUARDRAILS AROUND THE USE OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR IS RIGHTLY
FOCUSED ON REDUCING
BACKLOGS AND IMPROVING SERVICES
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND I THINK IN THAT REGARD,
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE REALLY
APPEALING.
BUT WE ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO LEARN FROM SEVERAL EXAMPLES
WHERE THE RAPID ADOPTION OF
TECHNOLOGY
OFTEN I'LL MENTION,
WITHOUT SERIOUS INPUT FROM
WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES,
DRAG THE PUBLIC SECTOR IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION,
CREATING MASSIVE DELAYS,
WRONGFUL DENIALS AND VERY COSTLY
PROBLEMS THAT
THEN THE TAXPAYERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FIXING.
SO THE SENATOR JUST MENTIONED
A KEY EXAMPLE THAT I THINK IS
WORTH UNDERSCORING AND WAS
BROUGHT
UP EARLIER ABOUT ED.
WE SAW MASSIVE ISSUES DURING THE
PANDEMIC OF PEOPLE
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THEIR
BENEFITS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT BROUGHT ON
A FRAUD DETECTION ALGORITHM
THAT,
AS THE SENATOR SAID, REVIEWED
10 MILLION CLAIMS.
RIGHT.
IT REPLACED THE WORK OF A LOT
OF HUMANS TO MOVE QUICKLY.
IT FOUND 1.1 MILLION OF THOSE
WERE FRAUDULENT.
THEY CUT OFF THE WORKERS
PAYMENTS,
DIDN'T PROVIDE NOTICE TO THOSE
WORKERS,
BUT 600,000 OF THOSE WORKERS
CLAIMS WERE LEGITIMATE.
AND THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA.
THAT TECHNOLOGY WAS MARKETED
AND SOLD
TO 42 STATES IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S CURRENTLY THE SUBJECT OF
A COMPLAINT
AT THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION.
AND WE THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO SAY
BECAUSE AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA,
WE HAVE A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
OPERATION HERE.
WE'RE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD, RIGHT?
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE RECEIVING
A LOT OF MARKETING,
OF A LOT OF PRODUCTS THAT
PROMISE
A LOT OF EFFICIENCIES.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
PUTTING
REALLY CLEAR STANDARDS IN PLACE
TO ASSESS FOR THE RISK AND NOT
PUTTING
THAT BURDEN ON THE TAXPAYERS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS RECENT FROM
NEW YORK CITY.
THEY INCORPORATED AN AI POWERED
CHATBOT
MEANT TO PROVIDE RESIDENTS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT STARTING AND
OPERATING
A BUSINESS IN THE CITY.
WITHIN FIVE MONTHS, IT WAS FOUND
THAT THE CHATBOT REPEATEDLY
PROVIDED ADVICE TO THE PUBLIC
TO EXPLICITLY BREAK THE LAW.
SO QUESTIONS LIKE CAN I TAKE
A CUT OF MY WORKERS TIPS?
WOULD GET AN ANSWER FROM THE
CHATBOT THAT SAID,
YES, YOU CAN TAKE A CUT OF YOUR
WORKERS
TIPS AND PROVIDED CONFUSING BUT
LEGAL SOUNDING
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS ILLEGAL
PRACTICE.
OR QUESTIONS ABOUT HOUSING.
LIKE DO LANDLORDS HAVE TO ACCEPT
TENANTS ON RENTAL ASSISTANCE?
CHATBOT WOULD RESPOND NO,
LANDLORDS DO NOT HAVE
TO ACCEPT TENANTS ON RENTAL
ASSISTANCE,
WHICH IS FOR THE MOST PART,
A DIRECT VIOLATION OF A LAW THAT
SAID LANDLORDS
CANNOT DISCRIMINATE BASED ON
SOURCE OF INCOME.
WHAT DISTINGUISHES THE PUBLIC
SECTOR FROM THE PRIVATE
ACTORS WHO DEVELOP AND SELL THIS
TECHNOLOGY
IS THAT THE PUBLIC SECTOR IS
RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING SERVICES TO
EVERYONE,
AND ENSURING THAT THOSE SERVICES
ARE SAFE
AND NOT GOING TO FURTHER HARM
IN OUR LIVES.
I THINK ALL OF YOU KNOW WELL,
YOU HEAR FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
REGULARLY.
OUR COMMUNITIES COUNT ON US IN
SOME OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
AND VULNERABLE MOMENTS OF THEIR
LIVES,
AND THEY CANNOT BE USED AS
MARKET
RESEARCH OR EXPERIMENTS
FOR THESE PRIVATE COMPANIES WHO
ARE SELLING AN ALGORITHM.
SB 882 RECOGNIZES THIS REALITY
AND CALLS FOR
CLEAR STANDARDS FOR THE USE OF
AUTOMATED
DECISION MAKING AND AI SYSTEMS
IN HIGH RISK ENVIRONMENTS,
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST
THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
WE'LL MOVE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR PADILLA, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
I APPRECIATE MY WITNESS AND
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
THIS IS A MOTION BY JOE BORG.
SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED,
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I DODD I WILK I WILK I
ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO
GIL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I GLASER.
JONES.
NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I OKUBO.
COBO I PADILLA.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I.
SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
UH, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
ITEM NUMBER 11.
THAT'S SB 1402.
SENATOR MINH.
WELCOME AND GOOD MORNING.
AND PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
UH, WE'D LIKE TO START BY NOTING
THAT WE'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
SB 1402 WOULD REQUIRE ALL STATE
AGENCIES,
DEPARTMENTS, BOARDS, OFFICES,
COMMISSIONS AND CONSERVANCIES
TO CONSIDER
THE 30 BY 30 GOALS WHEN
ADOPTING,
REVISING OR ESTABLISHING THEIR
PLANS,
POLICIES OR REGULATIONS WHICH
DIRECTLY AFFECT LAND USE,
NATURAL RESOURCE MANAGEMENT,
WATER USE, AND QUALITY,
AND BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO ONE OF 25
GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS,
BUT THIS BIODIVERSITY IS UNDER
THREAT FROM CLIMATE CHANGE,
HABITAT LOSS AND FRAGMENTATION,
INVASIVE SPECIES,
DISEASE, PESTS AND POLLUTION.
CONSERVATION IS ONE OF THE BEST
TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE TO PREVENT FURTHER
EXTINCTIONS AND PROTECT OUR
BIODIVERSITY
AND ECOSYSTEMS.
IN 2020, GOVERNOR NEWSOM ISSUED
EXECUTIVE
ORDER NUMBER N 8220 TO ADOPT
A GOAL TO
CONSERVE AT LEAST 30% OF
CALIFORNIA'S LAND
AND COASTAL WATERS BY THE YEAR
2030.
TO ENSURE THIS GOAL REMAINED
A COMMITMENT
FOR FUTURE ADMINISTRATIONS.
LAST YEAR, I AUTHORED SB 337
TO CODIFY
THIS 30 BY 30 GOAL INTO STATUTE.
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
IN CONSERVATION TO FURTHER THIS
30 BY 30 GOAL,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS GOAL
ALSO BE ROOTED IN THE PLANS,
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS OF OUR
STATE AGENCIES.
TODAY, I HAVE WITH ME AARON
WOOLLEY,
SENIOR POLICY STRATEGIST FOR
SIERRA CLUB,
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1402.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR DODD,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS AARON WOOLLEY, AND
I'M A SENIOR POLICY
STRATEGIST WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA.
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
OUR HALF
A MILLION MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS, UM,
I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR MANN
FOR
SPONSORING THIS LEGISLATION
AND FOR THE CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR 30 BY 30.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN AMBITIOUS
VISION OF PROTECTING
30% OF OUR LANDS AND WATERS BY
2030 TO COMBAT THE DUAL CLIMATE
AND BIODIVERSITY
CRISIS IMPACTING OUR STATE.
SB 337, WHICH PASSED LAST YEAR,
CODIFIED 30 BY 30 AS A GOAL AND
SB 1402,
BUILDS ON THAT POLICY BY
ENSURING
THAT GOAL IS ALSO CONSIDERED
BY KEY AGENCIES AND OTHER STATE
DECISION
MAKING BODIES DURING PROCESSES
TO UPDATE OR ESTABLISH PLANS,
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS.
ACTING IN SILOS IS NOT AN
EFFECTIVE
POLICY MAKING STRATEGIES.
STATE AGENCIES, BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ARE ALREADY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING OUR
PUBLIC LANDS,
ENSURING OUR RIVERS, LAKES AND
COASTS ARE
CLEAN AND PROTECTING IMPERILED
WILDLIFE.
THESE ONGOING EFFORTS CAN AND
SHOULD, AT A MINIMUM,
CONSIDER 30 BY 30 AND ALIGN WITH
THEM WHEREVER POSSIBLE.
SOME EXISTING EFFORTS NATURALLY
ALIGN WITH 30 BY 30 GOALS
AND CAN PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION CO-BENEFITS.
FOR EXAMPLE, AS PART OF THE
STATE
WATER BOARD'S REGULATORY
PROCESS TO SET URBAN OUTDOOR
WATER EFFICIENCY TARGETS,
THE BOARD IS CONSIDERING HOW
TRANSFORMING URBAN
LANDSCAPES TO BE MORE DROUGHT
TOLERANT
CAN ALSO HELP SUPPORT
BIODIVERSITY LIKE
NATIVE PLANTS AND POLLINATORS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, FAILING TO
CONSIDER NATURE BASED
SOLUTION RISKS MINIMIZING OR MIS
MISSING MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL OPPORTUNITIES OR
SETTING POLICIES THAT
UNDERMINE OUR PROGRESS TO
ACHIEVE 30 BY 30,
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION
HAVE MADE GREAT STRIDES SETTING
POLICY
AND PROVIDING FUNDING IN RECENT
YEARS TO BUILD
MOMENTUM FOR 30 BY 30 IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE ALSO NEED ACCOUNTABILITY
AND COORDINATION AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO GUIDE STRONG
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND SB 1402 FILLS THAT GAP.
ACCOUNTING FOR RELEVANT STATE
POLICIES AND PLANNING
PROCESS IS A COMMON SENSE STEP
THAT
WILL HELP FACILITATE
TRANSPARENCY AND ALIGNMENT
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S DECISION
MAKERS.
WITH THAT, WE SUPPORT SB 1402
AND URGE
YOUR I VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
>> MICHAEL JARRETT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR BIODIVERSITY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI.
SAMANTHA SAMUELSON ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT,
SEMPERVIRENS FUND,
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION,
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE,
AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
DYLAN FINLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE SIERRA CONSORTIUM IN
SUPPORT.
>> NATALIE BROWN WITH THE
PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> MEGAN SHUMWAY, A CITIZEN OF
SACRAMENTO, IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THIS IS SB 1402.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION, I'LL MOVE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA.
AND, SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE?
NO.
I'M OKAY.
THANK YOU.
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR I
VOTE, THOUGH.
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
YES.
OKAY.
PERFECT.
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB 1402.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I DODD I WILK.
ALVARADO, GIL.
ALVARADO, GIL I.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY, BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I.
GLAZER.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
JONES.
WHEN?
OR CHOCOBO.
PADILLA.
PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I.
CELADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE, UH.
HAVE WE DONE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR?
NOPE.
YOU HAVE A MOTION ON THE WILK
MOVE.
IS WILK.
SENATOR WILK.
SECRETARY, PLEASE.
WHAT'S THAT?
OKAY.
VERY GOOD.
SO LET'S.
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
UH, SB 1009.
DOLLEY AS ITEM NUMBER THREE.
SB 1207.
DOLLEY.
UH, ITEM NUMBER TEN SB 1246
LIMON.
UH, ITEM NUMBER 12 SB 1461
ALLEN.
S ITEM NUMBER 15 SB 1044 CIERTO.
UH, ITEM NUMBER 17.
UH SB 1214.
WIN.
UH.
ITEM NUMBER 18 SB 1407.
WIN.
UH.
ITEM NUMBER 20, SB 1215 AS A
GEO.
AS AS IS SB 21 1519, WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR WILK.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I DODD I WILK I WILK
I ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO GIL
I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I ASHBY
BRADFORD BRADFORD
I GLASER JONES NGUYEN WIN I
OKOBO OKOBO I PADILLA
PADILLA I PORTENTINO PORTENTINO
I ROTH.
RUBIO I RUBIO I SATO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
BILL HAS TEN VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL AS WELL.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR SENATOR
HURTADO
AND SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHICH ONE IS IT NOW?
YEAH, WE'LL OPEN UP.
UH, WE'LL OPEN UP A FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE, SB 1104.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
WELL, ONLY YOU AND I WERE HERE.
BUT I SAID THAT I WOULD MAKE
THE MOTION WHEN APPROPRIATE.
YOU DID SAY THAT.
AND IT'S APPROPRIATE NOW.
SO IT'S GOT A MOTION BY WILK.
>> YOU WEREN'T LOOKING FOR ME,
THOUGH.
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE?
SB 1104.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
DODD I DODD I WILK A WILK I
ALVARADO
GIL A ALVARADO GIL I.
ARCHULETA A ARCHULETA I
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I GLAZER.
JONES.
JONES, I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I OKOBO.
OKOBO I PADILLA.
PADILLA, I PORTANTINO.
FIORENTINO, I.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO, I.
CITRO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SAT 1111.
IT'S A BELOVED VOTES.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL.
WHO?
WHAT'S THAT?
FILE ITEM NUMBER 15.
ALVARADO GIL 16.
EXCUSE ME, DO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
ON I MEAN, A.
WE'LL MOVE.
WE'LL MOVE THAT.
SO THAT'S MOTION.
UH, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB 1088 MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE.
DOT I DOT I WILK I WILK I
ALVARADO GIL I ALVARADO
GIL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY BRADFORD.
ALL RIGHT BRADFORD I GLAZER
JONES I'M SORRY, MR.
CHAIR.
I MISSED THE BILL.
THAT YOU'RE CALLING SB 1088,
ITEM NUMBER 16.
OVERALL JONES, I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN, I OKOBO.
OKOBO I PADILLA.
PADILLA, I PORTENTINO.
PORTENTINO I ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
BILL HAS 12 VOTES.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
UH, FILE ITEM NUMBER 19, SB 896,
AND SENATOR WILK WAS THE ONLY
ONE TO HEAR THAT.
SO I WILL MAKE THE MOTION.
THANK YOU.
UH, SO WE.
RELUCTANTLY.
A MOTION.
UH, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
DODD I DODD I WILL, I WILL I
ALVARADO
GIL I ALVARADO GIL I ARCHULETA
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY BRADFORD
BRADFORD I GLAZER JONES.
JONES I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I OKOBO OKOBO I PADILLA.
PADILLA I PORTENTINO.
QUARANTINE I ROSS.
RUBIO.
I SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
IT WAS 1111 VOTES.
WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL AS WELL.
AND WE HAVE SENATOR SKINNER.
GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME.
WE HAVE.
WHERE ARE WE?
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, SB 1073.
SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING AND START WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE PURPOSE OF SB 1073, WHICH IS
BEFORE YOU TODAY,
IS TO ACCELERATE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF
NEW PROCESSES AND TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN RESULT IN A MARKET
AVAILABLE
AND ECONOMICALLY VIABLE,
LOW CARBON CEMENT AND CONCRETE.
SO CEMENT AND CONCRETE REPRESENT
ABOUT 8% OF THE EMISSIONS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS TOTALLY
IN GLOBALLY.
AND WE OBVIOUSLY WITH OUR
HOUSING CRISIS,
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS,
WITH LOTS OF REASONS, LOOK AT
BRIDGES FALLING DOWN.
WE NEED CONCRETE.
SO IF WE CAN IF THERE IS THE WAY
TO PRODUCE CONCRETE
THAT IS LESS LOWER IN CARBON,
WE NEED IT.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES, IT'S
PERMISSIVE,
BUT IT ALLOWS STATE AGENCIES
TO ENTER INTO ADVANCED
PROCUREMENT
AGREEMENTS FOR LOW CARBON
CEMENT.
NOW, WHAT THAT DOES IS IT TELLS
THE MARKET AND IT TELLS THOSE
COMPANIES THAT ARE NOW PRODUCING
OR RATHER DEVELOPING THIS,
THAT, HEY, WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THIS KIND OF PRODUCT.
SO THEN INVESTORS GET OKAY,
THERE'S A MARKET FOR
THAT PRODUCT AND THERE'S MORE
INVOLVEMENT
THEN IN THE RESEARCH AND THE
TECHNOLOGY,
AND IT'S MORE LIKELY THAT WE
WILL THEN RECEIVE.
PRODUCTS THAT ARE LOW CARBON
CEMENT
THAT ARE ECONOMICALLY VIABLE.
SO IF AT THE END OF.
SO IT'S A TEN YEAR ADVANCED
PROCUREMENT.
IF AT THE END OF THAT THERE
AREN'T
GOOD PRODUCTS AND THEY DON'T
MEET
THE STATE'S NEEDS AND THEY DON'T
OUR TECHNICAL SPECIFICATIONS,
THE STATE DOES NOT HAVE TO
PURCHASE THOSE PRODUCTS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT USES
THIS ADVANCED PROCUREMENT
METHODOLOGY COMMONLY TO TRY TO
STIMULATE INVESTMENT
AND TO CREATE A MARKET FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION
OF DECARBONIZATION AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
IN EFFECT, CALIFORNIA DID THE
SAME THING WHEN
WE PASSED THE BILL THAT SAID
UTILITIES,
WE WANT UTILITY GRADE BATTERY
STORAGE.
WE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE AVAILABLE
BATTERIES
AT THE POINT THAT WE PASSED
THAT.
NOW WE'RE THE WORLD LEADER IN
LONG DURATION
OR NOT QUITE LONG DURATION,
BUT SHORT DURATION, UTILITY
GRADE, BATTERY STORAGE.
WE ARE THE WORLD LEADER.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONLINE THE
EQUIVALENT BATTERY
STORAGE OF FOUR DIABLO POWER
PLANTS.
AND YET, WHEN WE PASS THE BILL
THAT SENT THAT
MARKET SIGNAL BACK IN 2010, WE
HAD NONE.
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
DO HERE.
AND LET ME HAVE MY WITNESSES,
SIMON BRANDLER FROM
THE DECARBONIZED CEMENT AND
CONCRETE ALLIANCE,
AND CHRIS ROSA FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
MORNING CHAIR DOD AND MEMBERS
CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF NRDC ACTION
FUND.
SPONSOR.
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL, SB 1073,
IS A PERMISSIVE AND CLARIFYING
BILL.
IT MERELY AUTHORIZES STATE
AGENCIES TO
ENTER FORWARD CONTRACTS TO
PURCHASE
LOW CARBON CEMENT AND CONCRETE
PRODUCTS
UP TO TEN YEARS IN ADVANCE.
CLARIFYING SUCH AUTHORITY WILL
REMOVE
A KEY BARRIER INTO UNLOCKING
DEEP DECARBONIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S CEMENT SECTOR.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, CEMENT
PRODUCTION
IS THE SECOND LARGEST
INDUSTRIAL SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED
LEGISLATION INCLUDING SB 596,
REQUIRING ALL CEMENT USED IN
CALIFORNIA
TO BE NET ZERO EMISSIONS BY
2045.
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES,
INCLUDING ENSURING THE STATE
CAN PURCHASE LOW EMISSION CEMENT
AND CONCRETE,
WILL BE REQUIRED TO MEET THIS
GOAL.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY HAS
IDENTIFIED
ADVANCED PROCUREMENT MODELS AS
A TOOL NECESSARY TO SCALE LOW,
ULTRA LOW EMISSION CEMENT AND
CONCRETE.
AGAIN, SB 1073 CLARIFIES THIS
IS A TOOL
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES
CAN
DEPLOY IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
STATE'S
CEMENT DECARBONIZATION EFFORTS,
AND THIS WILL HELP BRING OUR
CLIMATE
TARGETS INTO REALITY.
THANK YOU TO SENATOR SKINNER FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL
AND TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION.
>> THANK YOU, CHAIR, DOD, VICE
CHAIR WILK,
AND MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY ON BEHALF OF DC2,
THE DECARBONIZED CEMENT AND
CONCRETE ALLIANCE,
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL 1073.
MY NAME IS SIMON BRANDLER,
AND I SERVE AS VP FOR POLICY
AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS AT BRIMSTONE,
AN OAKLAND,
CALIFORNIA, COMPANY WITH A
DEEPLY DECARBONIZED
PROCESS FOR MAKING INDUSTRY
STANDARD CEMENT.
WE HELPED FOUND DC2, WHICH NOW
CONSISTS
OF 11 INNOVATIVE, US BASED,
VENTURE BACKED COMPANIES WITH
SOLUTIONS TO
TACKLE CEMENT AND CONCRETE
EMISSIONS.
FOUR OF THOSE ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
PASSAGE OF SB 1073 WOULD MARK
A SIGNIFICANT
MILESTONE TOWARDS ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS
AND CLEANING UP A SECTOR THAT,
AS SENATOR SKINNER MENTIONED,
ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 8% OF GLOBAL
CARBON EMISSIONS.
HITTING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
TARGETS DEPENDS
ON PROCURING CEMENT AND CONCRETE
WITH
MUCH LOWER CARBON LEVELS THAN
ANYTHING
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE AT SCALE
TODAY.
SB 1073 WOULD CLARIFY THE
DISCRETION,
NOT THE OBLIGATION,
BUT THE DISCRETION OF CALIFORNIA
STATE AGENCIES TO SECURE
SOURCES OF THESE ESSENTIAL
MATERIALS
YEARS IN ADVANCE.
SIMILAR TO THE POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS USED
TO DEVELOP NEW SOURCES OF CLEAN
ENERGY.
STATE AGENCIES COULD USE FORWARD
CONTRACTS
TO ESTABLISH A PIPELINE OF
THE LOW CARBON MATERIALS THEY
NEED
TO ACHIEVE STATE CLIMATE
TARGETS.
AND CRITICALLY, THESE
COMMITMENTS WOULD ALSO
UNLOCK FINANCING FOR EMERGING
SUPPLIERS,
ALLOWING THEM, INCLUDING
BRIMSTONE,
TO SCALE PROCESSES SOONER
AND BRING TRANSFORMATIONAL ULTRA
LOW CARBON CEMENT AND CONCRETE
SOLUTIONS TO THE MARKET.
SB 1073 WOULD PUT CALIFORNIA AT
THE FOREFRONT OF A GROWING
NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL EFFORT THAT
INCLUDES
THE US STATE DEPARTMENT.
I'M SORRY, THE US DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AND THE FIRST
MOVERS COALITION TO USE FORWARD
AGREEMENTS,
ALSO CALLED ADVANCE MARKET
COMMITMENTS, TO CATALYZE
THE CLEAN INDUSTRIAL TRANSITION
FOR CEMENT AND CONCRETE.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE SENATOR
SKINNER
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR ITS CONSIDERATION.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND COLLABORATING WITH YOU ON
THIS IN THE WEEKS TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT?
GOOD REMINDER TO STATE YOUR
NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M MEGAN SHUMWAY, AND ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO
350 AND CLIMATE ACTION
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> CAROLYN VEALE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF ARGENT MATERIALS,
AN ECO FRIENDLY CONCRETE AND
ASPHALT RECYCLING
COMPANY BASED IN EAST OAKLAND,
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AARON WOOLLEY ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MR.
CHAIR MEMBERS SCOTT GOVAN ON
BEHALF OF
THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION,
THEY'RE THE LARGEST UNION
SIGNATORY
BUILDING CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE.
THEY HAVE NO ISSUES WITH GREEN
CONSTRUCTION.
AS THE ANALYSIS NOTES, MANY
STATE AGENCIES
ARE SPECKING GREEN MATERIALS.
TODAY, CALIFORNIA HAS THE BUY
CLEAN,
WHICH APPLIES TO OTHER
MATERIALS.
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD.
WE HAVE THE SAME QUESTIONS WITH
THIS BILL
THAT WE HAD WITH LAST YEAR'S
BILL,
AND IT'S REALLY OPERATIONAL
QUESTIONS,
EVEN IF IT'S PERMISSIVE.
THE STATE DOESN'T PROCURE
CONCRETE.
WE DO.
SO IF THE STATE'S GOING TO GET
INTO
THE SPACE OF PROCURING CONTRACT
CONCRETE,
THEN YOU HAVE ALL THESE
LIABILITY QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT IF THE STATE
SUPPLIER DOESN'T SHOW UP?
WHO'S LIABLE FOR LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES?
SHOULDN'T BE THE CONTRACTOR.
SINCE WE'RE BUYING FROM THE
STATE,
IT'S GOT TO BE THE STATE.
IF THAT PRODUCT FAILS AGAIN,
THE STATE'S THE PROCURING
ENTITY.
THEY NEED TO BE LIABLE FOR THAT.
IF THERE'S AN INSUFFICIENT
SUPPLY OF THAT MATERIAL,
THE STATE SHOULD BE OBLIGATED
TO CHANGE
SPECIFICATIONS AND PAY CHANGE
ORDERS.
SO AGAIN, THIS IS NOT HOW
PROCUREMENT WORKS TODAY.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO CREATE
THIS PERMISSIVE AUTHORITY
THEN WE NEED TO ADDRESS THESE
UNDERLYING QUESTIONS
PARTICULARLY AS THEY RELATE TO
LIABILITY WHICH
IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
CONSTRUCTION.
IT HAS BEEN FOREVER AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
>> MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRETT
BARROW
WITH THE UNITED CONTRACTORS,
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE
OF THE PLUMBING,
HEATING PIPING INDUSTRY, AND
THE WESTERN LINE CONSTRUCTION.
AND.
WELL, I WANT TO ECHO A LOT OF
WHAT CEA HAS SAID.
I WANT TO ADD TO THAT.
CONCRETE IS ONE OF THOSE COMPLEX
AREAS OF CONSTRUCTION IN
THAT WE HAVE TO MEET BID
SPECIFICATIONS
OF THE STATE,
DEALING WITH THOUSANDS OF BLENDS
OF CONCRETE FOR STRUCTURE,
COLOR, TEMPERATURE,
EVERYTHING THAT COULD BE
VARIABLES
ON THE JOB SITE AT THE TIME.
AND PLUS CONCRETE DOESN'T TRAVEL
WELL.
WE HAVE TO GET IT FROM THE
SOURCE THAT'S
CLOSE TO THE SITE THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE POURING
LARGE HIGHWAYS WHERE
WE HAVE TO HAVE A CONTINUAL
CHAIN OF TRUCKS
COMING IN AND KEEP THAT CHAIN
GOING AS LONG
AS WE'RE DOING THAT PARTICULAR
SECTION.
SO OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE
LIABILITY
AND THE AVAILABILITY AND OF
COURSE,
THE PRICING OF THESE LONG TUM
PURCHASE AGREEMENTS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE 1073.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS TODD BLUMSTEIN,
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
JUST TWO BRIEF POINTS.
ONE, THE SOURCES WHERE CONCRETE
AND CEMENT ARE PRODUCED,
THOSE ARE STATIONARY SOURCES
AND THEY'RE
REGULATED BY THE AQMD ACROSS
THE STATE.
SO AND THAT'S SUBJECT, OF
COURSE, TO CAP AND TRADE.
SECOND QUESTION OR SECOND ISSUE
IS I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE SPONSORS TO WORK WITHIN
CALTRANS.
THEY HAVE A COMMITTEE DESIGNED
CALLED
THE CALTRANS PAVEMENT MATERIALS
PARTNERING PARTNERING COMMITTEE
THAT LOOKS AT PRODUCTS
THAT THE THAT INDUSTRY WANTS
TO PRESENT
THEM SO THEY CAN RESEARCH
THEM AND TEST THEM BEFORE THEY
GET OUT ONTO OUR HIGHWAYS.
SO I'D ENCOURAGE THAT APPROACH
RATHER THAN THE LEGISLATURE
SAYING WE SHOULD USE A
PARTICULAR TYPE OF CONCRETE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY, SO WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TURN BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO.
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL.
SENATOR ARCHULETTA.
YEAH.
UH.
>> SENATOR, I'VE GOT SOME
QUESTIONS,
PROBABLY TO YOUR EXPERTS.
I GUESS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONCRETE,
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STORAGE.
AND WHEN I THINK OF CONCRETE,
I KNOW IT'S SAND
AND GRAVEL AND ROCK AND IT'S
MADE TOGETHER,
AND ALL IT IS, IS ALL THESE
ELEMENTS GOING
TO BE STORED SEPARATELY AND
PURCHASED,
OR THEY MENTIONED ABOUT
DISTRIBUTION,
OR DIFFERENT VENDORS ARE GOING
TO COME AND BUY
FROM THE STATE THIS AUTHORIZED
CONCRETE.
HOW IS ALL THAT WORKING
TOGETHER?
UM, THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
THE WHILE THE BILL REFERENCES
CEMENT
AND CONCRETE BECAUSE CONCRETE,
UH, ALMOST ALL CONCRETE HAS
CEMENT.
ALL CEMENT ISN'T NECESSARILY
CONCRETE,
BUT THE REAL FOCUS OF THE BILL
IS
ON THE PRODUCTION OF THE CEMENT,
BECAUSE IT IS THE CEMENT MIX OR
THE PROCESS OF PRODUCING CEMENT,
THAT WHERE ALL THE GREENHOUSE
GASES COME
IN AND WHERE CEMENT IS UNIQUE
IS THAT,
YOU KNOW, EVEN IF WE GO TO 100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
SO THE KILNS THAT PRODUCE CEMENT
ARE COMPLETELY POWERED BY,
YOU KNOW, NON, UH,
NO EMISSION POWER THERE IS STILL
IN IN THE WAY THAT
WE PRODUCE CEMENT NOW BECAUSE
OF LIMESTONE,
THERE IS STILL A SIGNIFICANT
WHAT
THEY CALL PROCESS EMISSIONS.
LIMESTONE IS BROKEN DOWN AND
CARBON IS EMITTED.
WHAT THESE DIFFERENT UM,
COMPANIES ARE NOW DOING IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
LIMESTONE
REQUIRED TO USE OTHER MIXES,
OTHER, UH, INGREDIENTS, IN
EFFECT, TO MAKE CEMENT.
AND IF THEY CAN PULL THAT OFF IN
AN ECONOMICALLY VIABLE WAY,
THEN WE'LL HAVE A CEMENT PRODUCT
THAT IS LOW CARBON.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT REAL
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW,
BUT IN TEN YEARS, IT'S POSSIBLE.
SO I MADE THE ANALOGY TO THE
BATTERY STORAGE,
BECAUSE AT THE POINT THAT WE
SENT THAT SIGNAL,
IT WAS NOT REALLY AVAILABLE AT
THAT TIME,
BUT IT BECAME AVAILABLE.
SO THIS BILL, COMPARED TO MY
PREVIOUS ATTEMPT AT THIS,
MY PREVIOUS ATTEMPT WAS
REQUIREMENT.
THIS ONE IS PERMISSIVE.
THIS ONE GIVES THE AGENCIES
THE AUTHORITY IF THEY CHOOSE TO,
TO ENGAGE IN SOME ADVANCED
PROCUREMENT,
BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE THEM TO.
AND THIS IS WHERE I WOULD, UH,
UM, RESPOND TO THE OPPOSITION.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE THE STATE
AGENCIES TO
MAKE THAT PURCHASE IN THE TEN
YEARS TIME,
BECAUSE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE
WILL
NOT HAVE THE PRODUCT AVAILABLE,
IT WILL NOT MEET THE
SPECIFICATIONS WE NEED.
AND SO, OF COURSE, WE WOULD
NEVER FORCE
THE STATE TO THEN PURCHASE IT.
SO THIS IS MORE TO SEND THAT
SIGNAL LIKE,
YES, RESEARCHERS, DEVELOPERS,
INVESTORS.
YOU KNOW, UH, WE'RE LOOKING FOR
A PRODUCT LIKE THIS.
WE'D LOVE TO SEE IT DEVELOPED
AND WE'LL WE'LL INDICATE
OUR INTEREST BY THESE ADVANCED
PROCUREMENTS.
BUT IF IT ISN'T MET, WE WILL
NOT PURCHASE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
I'M JUST GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT QUESTION.
UM, BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT UP,
I THINK, SOME INTERESTING
POINTS.
WHILE THE STATE IS NOT
PURCHASING THIS,
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
I'M THINKING, IS THAT THE STATE
WOULD, UH.
NEGOTIATE WITH THE CONTRACTORS,
THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD BUY IT,
TO INSIST,
IF IT'S READILY AVAILABLE TO
PURCHASE
THESE PRODUCTS THAT THE.
STATE SENDS, THE STATE DOES SET
SPECIFICATIONS AND SUCH.
UM, AND THE STATE ACTUALLY DOES
DO A LOT OF PURCHASING.
SO I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
ERROR THERE.
IN FACT, WE ARE THE THE LARGEST
PURCHASER
OF CEMENT IN THE WITHIN THE
STATE.
THE STATE IS THE LARGEST
PURCHASER.
UM, UH, AND THEY MAY BE DOING
THAT THROUGH SUBCONTRACT,
BUT THEY STILL ARE THE
PURCHASER.
UM, SO, UH, WE.
WHAT WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO DO
IS THE SAME
WAY THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES.
AND MY WITNESSES TALKED ABOUT
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
AND OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES USE
THIS KIND OF SIGNAL,
ENGAGING IN ADVANCED PROCUREMENT
TO SAY, YEAH,
WE WANT WE WANT TO TELL THE
MARKET, YEAH,
WE'D LIKE PRODUCTS LIKE THIS,
BUT WHERE THIS BILL WHERE I'M
CLEAR,
IS THAT IF THOSE PRODUCTS DO NOT
MEET OUR NEEDS
AND THEY ARE NOT ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE,
THEN WE KNOW STATE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PURCHASE THEM.
BUT IT IS TELLING THE INDUSTRY,
YEAH,
WE'D LIKE TO SEE YOU DEVELOP
THIS.
GREAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR
ALVARADO?
GIL.
UM, SENATOR SKINNER, I'M
INTRIGUED BY YOUR BILL.
UM, THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT,
AS I AM LEARNING MORE ABOUT
MEETING
OUR 2030 GOALS, CLIMATE GOALS,
AND UNDERSTANDING SOME OF THE
NEW GREEN
PRACTICES THAT I BECAME FAMILIAR
WITH,
THE STATS AROUND CEMENT BEING
A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO,
UH, THE THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FACE HERE.
AND IN THAT I ACTUALLY FOUND A,
A BUSINESS THAT IS WITHIN
AMADOR COUNTY AND THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT,
UM, THAT HAD SOME INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO
DEVELOPING LOWER CARBON CEMENT
MIXES.
SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT YOUR BILL
BECAUSE
IT IMPACTS MY DISTRICT DIRECTLY.
UM, AND I HOPE THAT AS YOUR BILL
MOVES FORWARD,
THAT YOU WOULD ALLOW ME TO
CONNECT
YOU WITH PURE BASE,
WHICH IS A COMPANY THAT HAS
MASTERED THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND THE SCIENCE AND
HAS
CURRENTLY PROCURING ALL OVER
THE WORLD,
AND NOT SO MUCH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT THIS AND HOPE THAT
YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION
TO CREATE THAT PARTNERSHIP.
GREAT.
ANYBODY ELSE?
I HAVE A QUESTION.
YES, JUST A QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY, UM DO WE HAVE
ANY ESTIMATES
AS TO HOW MANY COMPANIES, UM,
CURRENTLY PRODUCE CEMENT AND
CONCRETE IN OUR STATE
AND HOW MANY ACTUALLY WOULD FALL
WITHIN
THESE PARAMETERS OF BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE CLEAN,
CLEANER, UH, CEMENT AND
CONCRETE?
UM, WELL, WE HAD THE, UH,
ONE OF MY WITNESSES FROM AN AN
INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION INDICATED,
AND PERHAPS HE COULD COME BACK
AND SAY THE EXACT
NUMBER SO THAT I DON'T, UH, MAKE
IT INACCURATE.
HE REFERENCED THE NUMBER OF
COMPANIES
THAT ARE NOW ENGAGED
IN TRYING TO PRODUCE THESE KIND
OF PRODUCTS.
UM, AND SOME OF THEM ARE BASED
IN CALIFORNIA.
HE MENTIONED THAT ALSO.
WILL YOU REFERENCE THAT?
SURE.
SO OUR OUR ALLIANCE HAS 11
COMPANIES.
FOUR OF THEM ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I WOULD ALSO NOTE WE ARE
REPRESENTING
SORT OF VANGUARD CLIMATE TECH
COMPANIES,
BUT THE INCUMBENT PRODUCERS ARE
ACTUALLY
MAKING A PRIORITY AROUND THIS
AS WELL.
AND THEY, FOR EXAMPLE, UM,
RECENTLY WERE AWARDED A DOE
GRANT
TO MAKE A CARBON NEUTRAL CEMENT
PLANT IN IN CALIFORNIA.
SO IT'S NOT JUST THE THE SORT
OF INNOVATIVE
COMPANIES THAT ARE PART OF DC2,
BUT THERE'S A BROADER COHORT OF
LOW CARBON CEMENT AND CONCRETE
COMPANIES THAT WOULD BE
CATALYZED
BY LEGISLATION LIKE THIS.
I'M SORRY.
SO.
SO TO BE CLEAR, THE QUESTION WAS
HOW MANY COMPANIES
DO WE HAVE CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND UNDER THOSE?
OUT OF THOSE NUMBERS, WE HAVE
CURRENTLY FOUR.
WELL, SO.
THERE ARE FOUR COMPANIES THAT
ARE WITHIN
HIS ASSOCIATION THAT ARE AND I
ARE MORE
VERY SPECIALIZED AND REALLY
FOCUSED SOLELY
AND ONLY ON THIS VERY LOW
CARBON.
YES.
UM, PRODUCTION.
NOW WE HAVE MANY OTHER CEMENT
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW MANY ARE THAT?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
AND I APOLOGIZE THAT I CAN'T
REMEMBER THAT EXACT NUMBER.
BUT THOSE CEMENT PRODUCERS,
SOME OF THEM JUST AS HE AS HE
DESCRIBED,
ARE ACTIVELY ALSO ENGAGED IN
TRYING
TO REVISE THEIR PROCESSES,
CHANGE THEIR TECHNOLOGIES,
NOT SOLELY AND ONLY BECAUSE OF
A BILL LIKE THIS,
BUT BECAUSE, FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS IN
STATUTE.
BY THAT, BY A CERTAIN YEAR,
YOU'VE GOT TO WAY REDUCE THOSE
EMISSIONS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
SENDING THOSE SIGNALS.
SO THE SIGNALS ARE BEING SENT
TO INCENTIVIZE
ALL OF OUR PRODUCERS,
OUR SPECIALTY ONES LIKE D TWO
REPRESENTS AND EVEN
OUR EXISTING CEMENT PRODUCERS
TO TO TRY TO,
YOU KNOW, HELP SUPPORT THEM IN
MAKING THESE INNOVATIONS IN
CEMENT PRODUCTION TO BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THAT LOW CARBON.
MR.
CHAIR, I WAS WONDERING, DO YOU
THINK
MAYBE THE OTHER WITNESSES MIGHT
HAVE
THE INFORMATION AS FAR AS HOW
MANY OR DO
OUR CONSULTANTS HAVE THAT
INFORMATION?
WE THE CONSULTANTS DO NOT UM.
THE.
WE MIGHT HERE.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION,
BUT THE COMPANY THAT I'M I'M
REPRESENTING UM ARGENT MATERIALS
IS NOT PART OF THE DC TWO.
SO IT IS ANOTHER COMPANY BASED
IN CALIFORNIA THAT PRODUCES,
UM CARBON NEUTRAL, CARBON
NEUTRAL.
SO A TOTAL OF FIVE THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY AWARE OF.
SO I DON'T THINK IF THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THAT
HAS ANY KIND OF AWARENESS OF
APPROXIMATELY
HOW MANY CEMENT MANUFACTURERS
THERE
ARE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I USED TO KNOW, I JUST DON'T
WANT TO PUT
FORWARD A NUMBER BASED ON MY
MEMORY.
THAT COULD BE VERY INACCURATE.
THAT'S.
>> UH, RYAN MCCARTHY WITH
WEIDMAN GROUP.
UM, I BELIEVE THERE ARE 7 OR
8 CEMENT
FACILITIES IN THE STATE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY COMPANIES
OPERATE THEM.
I THINK IT'S PROBABLY LESS THAN
THAT.
UM.
BUT THEN THE OVERALL CONCRETE
SPACE IS MUCH BROADER.
THERE'S A LOT I THINK THERE'S
HUNDREDS
OF CONCRETE MANUFACTURERS,
BUT THERE'S OTHERS WHO PROBABLY
HAVE BETTER ANSWERS TO THAT.
OKAY.
UH.
ANYBODY ELSE?
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE?
YES.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR.
SO.
DIFFERENT THAN MY PREVIOUS BILL.
THIS DOES NOT.
IT DOES NOT HAVE THE MANDATE OR
THE REQUIREMENT.
IT IS PERMISSIVE.
IT ALLOWS THE AGENCIES IF THEY
CHOOSE TO.
AND THEN AND IF THEY DO SO
AND THEY SEND THAT SIGNAL AND
SAY,
YES, WE'RE INTERESTED IN THIS,
WE'RE GOING TO SEND YOU OUT SOME
INTEREST
IN THIS ADVANCED PROCUREMENT.
BUT IF AT THE POINT THAT THEY
ARE PROCURING THOSE PRODUCTS,
DO NOT MEET THE SPECIFICATIONS
OR
DON'T CAN'T COMPETE WITH THE
BID,
THEY WILL NOT HAVE TO PROCURE.
SO WITH THAT, I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR RUBIO, DID YOU HAVE THE
MOTION ON THIS?
>> I DID ASK.
SO THE MOTION IS BY SENATOR
RUBIO ON SB 1073.
THE BILL HAS BEEN A THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
DODD.
I DODD I WILL I WILL I ALVARADO
GIL I ALVARADO GIL I ARCHULETA
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY BRADFORD
BRADFORD I GLAZER JONES.
JONES I NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I OKOBO.
PADILLA.
PADILLA I.
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO I.
ROSS.
RUBIO.
I.
SALADO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
GREAT.
BILL HAS 11 VOTES.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THAT.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO OUR
LAST ITEM NUMBER SIX.
IT'S SB 1157.
SENATOR GLASER, IF YOU OR YOUR
STAFF IS LISTENING,
IT'S HIGH TIME YOU CAME TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING.
PLEASE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OTHER
SENATORS
THAT MAY BE IN OTHER COMMITTEES.
UH, PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY DOWN
HERE SO WE CAN CLOSE OUT.
UH, SENATOR HURTADO, YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER SIX, SB 1157.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB 1157,
A BILL THAT CLARIFIES HUMAN
TRAFFICKING
AND FORCED LABOR DEFINITIONS,
SETS RULES FOR GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS,
REQUIRES COMPLIANCE PLANS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS,
AND OUTLINES PROCEDURES TO
ADDRESS
LABOR ISSUES AND SUPPLY CHAINS.
UM, I WILL ALSO BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
UH, PUBLIC PROCUREMENT IS A
SIGNIFICANT
PART OF GLOBAL GDP,
HIGHLIGHTING CALIFORNIA'S
POTENTIAL
TO INFLUENCE WORKING
CONDITIONS WORLDWIDE THROUGH
ITS POLICIES.
AND FOR FAR TOO LONG,
THE UGLY TRUTH OF FORCED LABOR
HAS
LURKED BEHIND THE SCENES OF
COUNTLESS INDUSTRIES.
FORCED LABOR IS FOUND IN
VIRTUALLY ALL INDUSTRIES,
AND FOR MANY DECADES HAS PLAGUED
SUPPLY
CHAINS AND TAINTED THE PRODUCTS.
THEY HELP CREATE.
REPORTS FROM THE BUREAU OF
INTERNATIONAL
LABOR AFFAIRS AND THE US
DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR REVEALS THE STAGGERING
ARRAY OF GOODS
SPANNING 159 CATEGORIES FROM 78,
70, 78 COUNTRIES FIND THEIR WAY
INTO AMERICAN
MARKETS TAINTED BY THE STAIN OF
FORCED LABOR,
VIOLATING BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS
AND INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS.
CALIFORNIA, AS THE I BELIEVE
IT'S I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S THE FIFTH OR THE
FOURTH,
BUT SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE,
THE LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
HAS DONE
LITTLE TO FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATION
TO BETTER RESPOND TO AND PREVENT
LABOR TRAFFICKING.
SB 1157 WOULD REVISE EXISTING
LAW BY REQUIRING
THAT ANY BUSINESS THAT WISHES
TO CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA COMPLIES
WITH UPDATED PROVISIONS
CURRENTLY IN FEDERAL REGULATIONS
IN 2016,
TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND PREVENT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND OTHER FORMS OF LABOR.
ANNUALLY, THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT PROCURES
ABOUT $20 BILLION IN GOODS AND
AND SERVICES.
IN PASSING SB 1157, THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ENSURING
OUR PROCUREMENT SYSTEM HAS THE
SAME EXPLICIT
PROTECTION STANDARD AS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS FOR
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS TO PREVENT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THIS BILL IS A MAJOR OVERDUE
STEP IN
CREATING TRUE PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES
TO ADDRESS FORCED LABOR AND
EXPLOITATION
IN OUR PROGRESSIVE STATE,
AND HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT,
I HAVE, UH, STEPHANIE.
RICHARD.
AND I HAVE FLOOR.
MOLINA.
>> UM, GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING.
MY NAME IS PROFESSOR RICHARD.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE ANITA
JANE ANTI-TRAFFICKING
INITIATIVE AT LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
HERE WITH
YOU TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE
OF LEGISLATION TO PREVENT
TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA AND GLOBALLY.
THERE'S NO EASY SOLUTIONS TO
PREVENTING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
HOWEVER, FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE,
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
EXPERTS
AGREE THAT TAKING STEPS TO
COMBAT TRAFFICKING AND
GOVERNMENT
PROCUREMENT CONTRACTS
CAN PREVENT TRAFFICKING BEFORE
IT STARTS.
BASED ON OVER TEN YEARS OF
LEARNING
HOW TO BETTER PREVENT
TRAFFICKING BEFORE IT STARTS AND
SUPPLY CHAINS,
SB 1157 PROVIDES SPECIFIC AND
DETAILED GUIDANCE
TO CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS ON
CONCRETE
ACTIONS THEY MUST TAKE TO ENSURE
GOODS MADE
FOR CALIFORNIA ARE PRODUCED
ETHICALLY.
THIS PROPOSED LEGISLATION ALSO
SUPPORTS BUSINESSES AS
IT'S MODELED ON EXISTING FEDERAL
STANDARDS CREATED
EIGHT YEARS AGO THAT COMPANIES
HAVE ALREADY HAD
TO COMPLY WITH TO RECEIVE
FEDERAL CONTRACTS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
WHO CONTRACT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT
ALREADY HAVE TO MEET FEDERAL
PROCUREMENT
STANDARDS ON TRAFFICKING,
AND CALIFORNIA'S STATE LAW WOULD
REINFORCE THESE
BEST PRACTICES TO PREVENT
TRAFFICKING.
SINCE CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD,
THIS MEASURE CAN HAVE STATE AND
GLOBAL IMPACT.
FURTHER, A LOT OF CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES,
TECH, CONSTRUCTION, AUTOMOBILES,
SOLAR FOOD PROCESSING ARE
ALREADY
FACING THESE REGULATIONS,
AND AS THEY SEEK TO MEET THEM,
THEY SHOULDN'T BE UNDERCUT BY
THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GOVERNMENT GIVING
CONTRACTS
TO THOSE WHO AREN'T MEETING
THESE MINIMUM
STANDARDS OR TRYING TO MEET
THEM.
THE MINIMUM FLOOR STANDARDS IN
SB 1157
HELP ALL COMPANIES KNOW WHAT
THEY
NEED TO DO TO PREVENT
TRAFFICKING
AND REINFORCE ETHICAL PRACTICES.
THIS INCLUDES SUCH THINGS AS
HAVING
PROTOCOLS AND PRACTICES IN
PLACE THAT ENSURE NO RECRUITMENT
FEES ARE PAID BY WORKERS,
A WAY THAT OUR THAT WORKERS ARE
COMMONLY ENTRAPPED
IN DEBT BONDAGE OR MODERN
SLAVERY.
HAVING A POLICY THAT SAYS THAT
COMPANIES
CANNOT HOLD THE IDEAS OF
WORKERS.
ALSO EXPLICITLY, IN CALIFORNIA
CRIMINAL LAW,
THAT SAYS HOLDING AN IDEA OF
A WORKER
IS PER SE TRAFFICKING IF IT
CAUSES
SOMEONE TO PERFORM WORK AND
GUARANTEED REPATRIATION
IF THEY WANT TO LEAVE A BAD
WORK ENVIRONMENT, THEY CAN.
THEY NOT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE HELD
AGAINST THEIR WILL.
SB 1157 IS ALSO EASY TO
IMPLEMENT
AS ITS STATUTORY LANGUAGE,
ALTHOUGH IT LOOKS COMPLEX,
IS SOMETHING YOU CAN CUT AND
PASTE INTO EXISTING
LANGUAGE IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTS.
SO SB 1157 IS JUST THE TOOL.
OUR STATE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
NEEDS TO
STOP UNDERLYING ILLEGAL
WORKPLACE
AND HIRING PRACTICES THAT ARE
ALREADY
ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY,
AND CONSISTENTLY REINFORCE
ETHICAL
STANDARDS AND BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
FOR THESE REASONS, I ASK FOR
YOUR.
I VOTE ON SB 1157, AND I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE FLOOR MOLINA,
A SURVIVOR OF LABOR TRAFFICKING,
WHO WILL TESTIFY MORE ABOUT HER
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
>> GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING
TO ME TODAY.
MY NAME IS FLORA MOLINA AND I
AM A SURVIVOR
OF LABOR TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AM A.
HER TESTIMONY OF.
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA.
I WAS RECRUITED IN MY HOMETOWN
BY MY SEWING TEACHER,
TELLING ME THAT THERE WAS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
EVERYTHING WAS GOING TO BE PAID
FOR.
UM, WHEN I ARRIVED TO THE UNITED
STATES,
THEY WILL PROVIDE ME A PLACE
WHERE TO LIVE.
AND, UM, I DIDN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT ANYTHING.
WHEN I ARRIVED TO THE UNITED
STATES,
EVERYTHING WAS DIFFERENT.
I WAS, UM, IN A FACTORY WITH
50 OR 60 SEWING MACHINES.
I WASN'T ALLOWED TO PUT ONE STEP
OUTSIDE OF THE FACTORY.
I WAS NOT ALLOWED TO TALK TO MY
CO-WORKERS OR OTHER PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE I WAS WHEN,
UM.
WHEN I WAS DROPPED OFF AT, UM,
LOS ANGELES.
UM, I IT WAS DARK.
IT WAS RAINING.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANY PERSON IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I HAD ONLY TEN MINUTES TO EAT
WHATEVER THEY
PROVIDED ME DURING MY LONG
SHIFTS.
AND I WAS TOLD THAT IF I DIDN'T
DO WHAT THEY TOLD ME TO DO,
THEY WILL HURT MY FAMILY,
SPECIFICALLY MY CHILDREN BACK
HOME.
I WAS AFRAID, HUNGRY, TIRED,
AND I WASN'T ALLOWED TO TALK
TO ANYBODY.
NOBODY WAS THERE FOR HELP.
I THANK TO SENATOR HURTADO FOR
INTRODUCING.
SB 1157, BECAUSE BILLS LIKE 1157
WILL PROVIDE A CONTRACT
FOR PERSONS WHO WANT TO COME TO
THE UNITED STATES.
IT ALSO MANDATES THAT THE
CONTRACT
WILL BE IN THE NATIVE LANGUAGE
OF THE PERSON WHO IS COMING TO
THE UNITED STATES.
I WILL JUST SAY IT WILL BE
GREAT IF ALSO THEY PROVIDE
A NUMBER TO CALL IN CASE
ANYTHING GOES WRONG.
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS.
LAWMAKERS LIKE YOU ALL DO TO
FIGHT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I DON'T WANT ANY OTHER HUMAN
BEING
TO GO TO WHAT I WENT THROUGH,
BECAUSE HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS
STILL EXISTS,
AND IT'S A SHAME THAT IT HAPPENS
IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM SO BLESSED TO BE IN
CALIFORNIA,
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS TAKING AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR OTHER STATES
AND NATIONWIDE AND AROUND THE
AROUND THE GLOBE,
UM, AS AN EXAMPLE TO FIGHT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I CAN SAY
ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT ALSO I WANT TO URGE, UM,
THE COMMITTEE HERE TODAY,
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ON
1157.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PERSONAL TESTIMONY.
I'M TERRIBLY SORRY THAT YOU HAD
TO GO THROUGH THAT ORDEAL.
UNBELIEVABLE.
UM, ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE, TURN IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
UH, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WELL, I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
YOUR WITNESS, SENATOR.
WHAT A STATEMENT.
WHAT A HERO YOU ARE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
GOD BLESS YOU TO COME FORWARD
FOR ALL THE WOMEN
AND MEN AND CHILDREN WHO ARE
FACING THIS TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE CRIME OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
UH, AND I'M GLAD YOU WERE HERE.
SO WE CAN ALL HEAR SO IT CAN BE
BROADCAST THAT WE,
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY,
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD, HAVE TO
RESORT TO
SUCH TREATMENT OF OF A HUMAN
BEING.
UH, AND I THINK THAT ANY COMPANY
THAT IS
INVOLVED IN THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN
AWAY.
THE CONTRACTS, THE ABILITY TO
DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ALL THOSE WHO
ARE APPREHENDED TO BE
INCARCERATED
FOR TO THE FULL EXTENT OF THE
LAW.
AND YOUR ARTICULATION IS
AMAZING.
GRACIAS POR HABLA ESPANOL EN
INGLÉS.
PERO YO SÉ HABLA ESPANOL.
AND THANK YOU, DEL CORAZON.
SO I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
THAT IS AMAZING.
AND, SENATOR, UH, BRINGING THIS
FORWARD REALLY
OPENS A LOT OF DOORS TO A LOT
OF US.
AND I THINK THAT WE NOT ONLY
HAVE TO LOOK TO CALIFORNIA,
BUT THE SOURCES WHERE IT COMES
FROM.
AND I'M HOPING THAT THERE ARE
AGENCIES WITHIN OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT CAN
CROSS THESE BORDERS
AND FIND AND PARTICIPATE WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OTHER
COUNTRIES TO PREVENT THEM FROM
COMING HERE.
SO WHEN APPROPRIATE, I WILL, UH,
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BILL AND MOVE
IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE?
SENATOR RUBIO.
YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU TO TO
THE SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I MEAN, THIS CONTINUES TO BE A
REALLY BIG ISSUE
IN OUR IN OUR COUNTRY, NOT JUST
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND IT REALLY BREAKS MY
HEART.
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL FLOOR
FOR COMING FORWARD.
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
SHE
SAID IS SHE WAS IN A SEWING
CLASS AND SHE WAS RECRUITED BY
HER SEWING TEACHER.
SO IT'S NOT SOMEONE THAT JUST
CHOSE TO COME
OVER AND SEE HOW THEY BREAK
THE LAW.
BUT THIS IS HAPPENING.
SHE WAS OFFERED AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH SOME GREAT CONDITIONS,
AND THEY COME TO THIS COUNTRY
AND THEN THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN A IN THESE TYPES
OF SITUATIONS.
AND I'M, YOU KNOW,
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING
THIS BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS ALREADY AN EXISTING
FEDERAL PROCUREMENT
POLICY THAT EXISTS AND THAT
WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN AS
CALIFORNIANS
TO SAFEGUARD THESE INDIVIDUALS.
LIKE I SAID, SHE DIDN'T CHOOSE
TO COME.
SOMEONE RECRUITED HER,
WHICH IS WHAT'S HAPPENING OFTEN.
AND I KNOW I WANT TO JUST ALSO
THANK
THE THE SUPPORTERS AND THE
ADVOCATES.
I KNOW THAT I'M WORKING WITH
THEM ON ANOTHER
BILL THAT FOCUSES SPECIFICALLY
ON CHILDREN.
IT HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT AS
WELL,
WHERE NOT ONLY ADULTS BUT
CHILDREN ARE
BEING BROUGHT OVER AND THEY'RE
WORKING
IN THESE TYPES OF CONDITIONS.
SO.
SO I HOPE THAT NOT ONLY MY BILL
PASSES,
BUT YOURS AS WELL,
BECAUSE WE NEED TO TACKLE THIS
ISSUE NOT JUST FOR THE ADULTS,
BUT LIKE I SAID, MY BILL
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHILDREN,
UH, THERE THEY HAD CHILDREN
WORKING LATE
HOURS OF THE NIGHT WHERE ALL
THE WORKERS
IN THE DAYTIME HAD GONE HOME AND
AND THEY WERE WORKING FOR LONG
HOURS.
I MEAN, I CAN'T IMAGINE A HUMAN
BEING NOT
BEING ABLE TO SPEAK TO THEIR
COWORKERS,
GIVING TEN MINUTES TO EAT.
NONE OF US WOULD SURVIVE IN
THESE TYPES OF CONDITIONS.
SO I WANT TO JUST SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE GREAT SENATOR OF SANGER FOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
AND I'M TAKING MY TIME BECAUSE
I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IT HAPPENS EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN'T DEFEND THEMSELVES.
IN THE VERY LEAST, WE CAN DO IS
TO ENSURE THAT WHEN, YOU KNOW,
WE ALLOW PEOPLE TO TO GET
CONTRACTS AND BUSINESSES,
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE IF SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HAPPENS.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR STORY AND
YOUR ADVOCACY.
AND I ALSO LIKE TO, UM, IF I'M
NOT A CO-AUTHOR,
CO-AUTHOR TO THIS BILL AND MOVE
A BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
ENTHUSIASTICALLY,
I MIGHT ADD,
BY SENATOR ARCHULETA, I
APPRECIATE THAT.
UM, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS IS AMENDED TO LABOR
COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GOD, I DODD I WILK I I ALVARADO
GILL I ALVARADO
GILL I ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA
I ASHBY.
BRADFORD.
GLASER.
I JONES.
JONES.
I NGUYEN.
WHEN I OKOBO.
OKOBO I PADILLA.
PADILLA I PORTENTINO.
PORTENTINO I ROTH.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SALADO.
SALADO I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGAIN AT THE SENATOR?
BRADFORD'S HERE.
ASHBY.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS 12.
12 VOTES THAT WILL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR HURTADO.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO BILLS ON CALL.
SECRETARY.
CAN YOU.
WHAT'S THAT?
MAKE SURE YOU LEAVE IT OPEN.
AND DO WE HAVE AN IDEA IF
SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IS ON HER WAY?
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO THROUGH.
SOME MEMBERS CAN MOVE ON TO
THEIR DAY.
SO, SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
JONES.
JONES I.
ROTH.
CERRADO CERRADO I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
BILL HAS 13.
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
WE'LL NOW OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
SB 1073.
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
OCHOA.
BOW.
ROTH.
SALADO.
SIERRA I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
1212 VOTES WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB 11
1104.
NILO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT.
MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I ROTH.
CIERTO.
CIERTO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
15, 13, 13 BOATS.
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THAT ON
CALL.
WE'LL NOW OPEN FILE NUMBER SIX
SB 1157.
HURTADO BUT IS THERE ANYBODY NEW
IN THE ROOM SINCE WE DID THAT?
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON.
UH, FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
1325 DURAZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I.
GLASER.
I JONES.
JONES.
NO.
ROTH.
SATO.
NO.
995 AND SMALL BUSES ON.
9 TO 5.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS ON.
UH, KEEP IT THE ROLL OPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE, SB 1220.
LIMON.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I JONES.
I'M SORRY.
IS THIS LEMON?
UH.
NO.
JONES.
NGUYEN.
OKUBO?
NO.
OKOBO NO WRATH.
SATO.
NO SATO.
NO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
939393.
KEEP THAT ROLL OPEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 13 SB 892.
PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
BITE OFF ON THAT.
UH OH, I GUESS I MISSED.
MIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11, SB 1402
I APOLOGIZE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILKE.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I JONES.
NO.
JONES.
NGUYEN.
OKUBO.
ROTH.
SATO.
NO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS IS HERE.
EIGHT TWO.
DID YOU VOTE?
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS ONE EIGHT.
ITEM 11 1402.
THAT'S.
SENATOR MIN IS A.
NO ON THAT ONE.
OH, NO.
NO.
SMALLWOOD, CALVUS.
SMALLWOOD, CALVUS I.
9393.
THAT BILL IS OUT 9 TO 3 NOW.
MOVED TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 13,
SB 892.
PADILLA.
THIS TIME.
ABSENT.
MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I JONES I JONES I.
ROTH.
SALADO.
SIERRA I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
1414 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NOW OPEN THE ROLE OF FINAL ITEM.
NUMBER 14 SB 893.
PADILLA.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
JONES.
JONES I.
ROTH.
SALADO.
SIERRA I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
1414 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER 16 SB 1088.
ALVARADO GILL.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I ROTH.
SALADO I SIERRA I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
1414 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'LL NOW OPEN TO FILE.
WE'LL OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM
19 896.
DODD.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
GLASER.
GLASER I ROTH.
SALADO.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE.
HIGH SIERRA I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I.
14.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
TOP.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE CONSENT.
UH, COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CONSENT CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLER CANVAS.
I IT'S 14 ZERO 14.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB 1073.
SKINNER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ASHBY.
OCHOA.
BO.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I 13 ZERO 13 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB 1104.
NILO.
ASHBY.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
I FOR THE LAST 14.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX 1157.
HURTADO, SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL.
ASHBY.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I 14 ZERO 14 ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
UH, HOW ABOUT WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, SB
1325.
DURAZO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ASHBY.
ROTH.
9 TO 5.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
UH, WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE.
SB 1220.
LIMON, PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
ASHBY.
NGUYEN.
ROTH.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD WAS I.
OKAY.
10 TO 3, 10 TO 3.
TEN.
THREE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
UH, THIS CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS
FOR THE DAY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS ADJOURNED.
I NEED TO TALK TO YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD JOB.